hello everyone hello hello we're here on the screen because
there's a lot of life updates what a wild two days i've had
guys looking wild all right hello everyone good morning i i
just woke up that bed was oh my gosh okay it was worth it
the the mattress investment was so worth it not last night
though all right for story time guys so okay so it was like
a series of unfortunate events it's it's a series of very
unfortunate events uh starting from yesterday so you guys
don't know how um yesterday i had to cancel stream because
uh i didn't know how long it's gonna take to do the whole
mattress bed frame setup and everything um so also at the
end of stream i will finally give away three codes for gold,
gold, adventure gold, which is the game that I voice acted
in.
Anyway, so, uh, I finally got a new mattress and a new bed
and a new bed frame, new pillowcases.
Oh, not sorry, new pillows, not pillowcases.
I'm using my old one.
New pillowcases.
Uh, sorry, new pillows.
Pillows are old.
New pillows.
Uh, new bed sheets.
It's like bamboo bedsheets, be specific the bed sheets are
bamboo silk bed sheets so they are bougie they were not just
regular cotton that I've been sleeping on for my the rest of
my life for the rest of my life but I got bamboo silk so I
wanted to sleep in comfort I've never experienced bamboo bed
sheets before.
I was just like, oh my, I'm gonna go all the way out.
I'm gonna go all the way out for this, for this bed.
If I'm spending it all, I spend all my money on this new
bed, uh, right off the bat in one fucking go.
Yeah.
So, um, it's just, yeah, so I was just like, no more cotton
for this girl.
That's peasant shit.
No more garden.
I'm getting on some bamboo sheets now.
Anyway, so, you know, super excited.
Yeah, I was so fucking excited to try out my new fucking
bed.
Then the people came in, set everything up, and, you know,
constructed the bed and everything.
King size, by the way.
Upgraded from a queen to a king size.
Go all the way out.
And because I was like, it's been eight plus years.
By the way, when they removed the bed sheets from my old
mattress, I looked at it.
I was like, oh, it was bad.
It was so bad.
I looked at it.
I was just like, oh.
It was like, it was, let's just say there were a lot of
stains on there.
I've had that bed mattress for like eight plus years.
And it definitely had a lot of stains on it.
I don't know where some of these stains came from.
Anyway, so it was pretty bad.
It was so bad.
I look, they like perched it up.
I'm like, oh my God.
I slept.
Oh my God.
I slept on that for eight plus years.
And anyway, anyway.
So, so they were like, when they finally finished
everything, Then they finally finished everything.
They were like, oh, do you...
They're like, do not sleep on the bed mattress yet.
It has to expand.
The foam has to expand.
Please wait like two to three hours before you sleep on the
bed.
So the mattress can fully expand and it won't affect the
shape of the mattress.
So I was like, sweet, all right, I can wait that long.
I'll just wait two to three hours and I can finally lie
down.
so um so basically uh so what I first realized when after
they left I was just like where's the remote you know you
know that was the whole point why I bought this particular
mattress because I was hoping that it could fold me like a
taco you know like when I when they're like with the
anti-snore feature and everything.
It doesn't have anti-snore features and all that jazz, you
know, all the features, all the electronics in my mattress.
And I was so confused.
I was just like, where's the remote to do all of that?
I don't understand.
Like, where is the remote?
Like, how am I supposed to, how is it supposed to move up
and down or like submerge me in the center?
If I don't have the remote, like where's the cool bank
technology that I was promised, you know?
And then, so I was very confused.
So like bed go up, bed go down.
How am I supposed to do that?
I don't have a remote for that.
So I called, I called the, like there was like a customer
service line.
And then, yeah, what's the feature that I paid for?
I called the customer service line.
And now I was like, hey, the people, the movies, forgot to.
Give me the remote and they're like oh, we're so sorry.
We're gonna we're gonna reach out to them and we'll call you
back So now I waited I sat on my chair because I couldn't be
on the fucking bed So I sat on the chair and also dad also I
didn't let dad on the fucking bed too And then so I sat on
the chair, you know Waiting also didn't put the bed sheets
yet because I was just like oh I'm just gonna wait until
ever I was worried that the bed sheets will put like will
fuck with the airflow and then it won't expand or anything
so anyway um i called uh i waited and then i waited for like
an hour and a half and i was just like where's the call like
like where is it so i was just like well you know i'll just
go walk to the store like the store is not that far off
where i bought the bed the everything all the everything
related to the bed like the new the um the bed sheets
everything so i went walked over there and i was just like
hey but then the and then i went in there and um there was
only like there was only one staff there at that time um but
the guy the main guy that sold me everything he wasn't
available because he doesn't go to work on that day he's
like oh she's like oh he comes in on friday if you want to
talk to him because he was the one that made my cell um he
was like this old man and then like his old grandpa and then
And so I was just like, oh, hey, they forgot to give me the
remote.
And I called them, but nobody called me back.
And I just want to know what the fuck happened to the
remote.
And she's like, oh, what's your order?
And I gave her the information and everything.
And she was like, oh, you just bought the mattress.
I was like, what?
Like, yeah, you didn't buy the frame that does all of that.
And I was just like, what do you mean?
Is that, is it not, not built into the mattress?
Are you telling me that the cool technology that I thought
is sold separately?
I don't know.
The whole point of the reason why I bought that particular
mattress was because that was like, it had anti-snore
features and it vibrates.
I was just like, oh my God.
I had vibration, massages, anti-snoir can fold me like a
fucking taco.
That was the whole reason why I bought that mattress.
And you're telling me that that was DLC.
I thought it was built into the mattress.
That was the whole reason why I bought that mattress.
No taco for you.
It was...
I was just like, I was just like, are you serious?
I was like, yeah, but you can buy it right now.
And I'm just like, what?
Tokey, please.
So I started thinking with a super chat.
Thank you.
The whole reason that the guy, the salesman, showed me that
mattress was because of the fucking folding features.
And I was like, I love this.
I'll take it.
And I was like, because I tried so many mattresses.
It was like, I don't know.
It all feel the same.
And they're like, I got a mattress for you.
And he's like, oh, look.
And he's like, look, it has all these features.
This mattress has all these features.
And I was just like, oh, that's so cool.
I love it.
And I just, the fact that the whole reason why I bought it
was just because of that feature.
I did not care about the mattress grape.
but that's the only reason why I bought that particular
mattress I didn't even realize that it's DLC that it's like
I thought it comes together you know
I thought it comes in the same it's like a set that's why I
bought it like I thought it came in a set and I was just
like raving about like oh I love it I love that I can put my
I can will it would uh the head part of the mattress can go
up and then if i want to like instead of stacking my pillows
i can just press the remote and then the mattress will go up
i was like i love that i love that feature oh my god the
anti-snore that's great i snore like i would love more
airflow i'll take i'll take this one it's great and the fact
that it was sold separately and then he didn't even sell me
that i was so in to pay more money for that i like and then
she was like the the lady that was there she was like yeah
um you didn't weren't charged for the for the uh you were
not charged for that frame for the for the uh i don't
fucking know what it's called the electronic frame i fucking
know what it's called i don't remember uh for that part you
were mattress.
I was just like, I don't care.
I just, I don't care because they already set everything up.
Like you can buy it right now if you want to.
And I was like, I don't fucking get, they already set it up.
I don't want to fucking have someone come in and reset the
whole thing up.
I was ready.
I was so ready.
Yeah, they showed me all the features, but they didn't even
include it in the sale.
I wasn't charged for it.
I was like, it's okay.
You weren't charged.
for it.
And I was just like, but I wanted it.
I wanted you to sell me more stuff.
I I want you to sell me the frame.
I actually wanted it.
I was ready to pay for it.
I was opening my wallet.
It was like, take the money.
I, why don't you want my money?
Why didn't you?
I was it really the scam if they wouldn't take my money like
is it really a scam like it hasn't even charged me for it
like anyway um so I was I was so sad I was like really
looking forward to I was ready I was looking ready I was
ready to be like full I was like a taco.
I was so I was ready to play around with the remote and be
like, woo!
Ben go up!
Ben go down!
I'm so excited!
I could go make Ben go up!
And I was like, oh, I can't wait to test the vibrations and
the end of the snore!
And then it's... I didn't get to.
I didn't even get the chance to.
It was never sold to me.
I didn't buy the DLC.
I... I can't believe it.
They didn't put the DLC in my cart.
I...
Like and they're like you can buy it now and we can have it
somehow send someone over to install it I was like it's too
late.
I wanted one trip not a fucking round trip.
I was not looking for I was not looking for a round trip
guys.
I was looking for a one-way trip like just set everything up
Never see any of you guys again.
Goodbye Maybe another eight to ten years.
I'll be back to buy the DLC but it's too late now it's too
late I don't want them to come back and do all of it again I
was like well and they're like anyway it's this amount and I
was just like you know what no I'm good I'm it was paying
everything together I'd be like okay this is all of it
investment together like combined together but then they
told me how much the DLC cost itself as well Okay, I'm gonna
go now.
I just been sorry.
You can call him on, you can call him on Friday.
He's gonna be everywhere.
He's like, no, it's all right.
It's okay.
It was a lot.
It was almost the same price as the mattress itself.
And I was just like, you know, if you put all, if they
combined all of it together with the mattress, I wouldn't
have noticed.
I would have just been like, because I was buying a lot of
stuff at the same time.
So I was just like, all right, that's all.
It's all good.
like because it was like it's all for me all this but then
now that i know the price separately from the mattress i was
just like it's fine it's you could have got me there i was
ready to be got i was ready on that day when i bought
everything you could have included it i you could have got
me but now i was ready i opened my wallet i was like here's
a blank check Just write whatever, what amount you want.
But now, now that I came back for one item, you don't got
me.
You don't got me there.
Hold on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Belford, the oldest trick of bed.
Sell, let me know.
Now you know what I'm going to tell the world is like.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Rector.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You never asked for the DLC.
I thought it was like in the bed.
I legitimately thought it was just a feature in the
mattress.
Because the guy never told us.
It's so two.
Never told us it was like two different things.
And I was just like, what do you mean?
Like, like he didn't even say it to him or myself.
He was just like, it's, he's like, do you like this
mattress?
It has all these features.
And I assumed that when he said it.
has all these features he's talking about the mattress I
didn't realize it was a separate thing because I was like I
love this bed because of all these features not because of
the mattress itself but all the features it had but he
didn't even include the fact the the fucking features like
when he sold it to me like
I don't understand.
I was even raving about it, too.
Being like, I love this.
I love all of these features.
This is why I picked this mattress.
Because it has all of these features.
But they didn't even give me the features.
I don't even have the features.
The whole point that popped this particular mattress was for
the features.
Yet, where are my features?
Reverse got him.
I got reverse.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh, Steve.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, the guy, the guy made you talk to me.
Notice I was afraid.
No, it looked like a mattress.
The mattress dipped in the middle.
It moved up.
It moved down.
It vibrated.
I thought it was all the mattress.
It blended so well.
It blended so well with the mattress itself.
You're at the store.
I swear to God.
Like.
It actually, like, looked like it was part of the mattress.
I did not notice it was not the mattress.
I did not at all.
So, anyway, so, I got my whole thing set up, by the way.
I was so looking forward to it.
Anyway, and they're like, oh, it should have said in your
receipt that you weren't sold, the, the thing that makes it
vibrate and I was like, I didn't even know there was a name
for it.
I saw the receipt, I found it.
It said mattress.
I assumed because I assumed the mattress did all of that.
So I thought the mattress was the thing because it was like
mattress, bed frame, bed sheets, boop, delivery.
I assumed mattress was the vibrating mattress.
I didn't a dlc i didn't want to clear i just thought it was
fine of the mattress
anyway so yeah they were like oh you come back on friday and
talk to the guy and just like to i don't know i guess he'll
give me a deal or some shit and be like oh i'm sorry for the
misunderstanding of everything like you're just i'm not i'm
I'm not.
I can't.
It's too late.
It's over.
It's fine.
I moved on.
I haven't moved on.
But I moved on.
I won't think about it.
I'm going to think about it.
I moved on.
Anyway, so,
um, I was sad, you know, So I was just like, you know what,
I'm going to treat myself for this sad day.
I'm going to go to a movie theater, the one where I can
drink.
There's some movie theaters here in my city where it's like,
basically it's like 18 plus movie theaters.
So no kids allowed type deal.
And you can order alcohol and stuff.
So you can drink.
Like it's like those like, it's like, it's like, I always go
to those movie theaters because then there's no kids there.
And I can just relax.
They have like reclining chairs.
And then you can order like food and drinks and stuff.
So I will go to these types of movie theaters.
Because A, there's no kids.
Which is great.
B, I can be drunk while watching a film.
There's no C.
That's really it.
I need to relax.
I was just like, I was so worked out.
I was like, I was really looking forward to playing with the
mattress.
Guys, you don't have no idea.
I was looking forward to recreating.
Bed go up, bed go down.
But now it's God.
My dream's God.
So, you know, came back home.
I got home.
He came home wallowing in pity about no taco dokey.
And so, you know, I was like, you know what?
I think the bed has expanded enough.
The mattress has expanded enough.
I put on the bed sheets and everything.
And And I'm just like, all right, you know what, um, you
know what, I'll, I'll put the stairs here, the dog stairs
here, I booked my tickets, I was like, I'm only going to be
gone for like two and a half hours, and then, so I'm just
going to, you know, go watch a movie, come back, bed's going
to be fully expanded, and then relax on my new comfy bed,
uh, so, foreshadowing, nothing surely is going to go wrong,
what a great foreshadowing, um, you fool so you know i went
and watched project hell mary because i've always wanted to
watch that movie and i heard it it was really really good
and it was it's been playing in the theaters for two months
already but still tickets were almost being sold out also by
the way i wish i took a picture of it but when i went there
there was this girl with an ita bag of kenny omega and I was
like, who's that?
That guy looks so familiar.
Is that Kenny Omega?
And I was just like, I couldn't tell at first.
I was like, oh my God, no, this is Kenny Omega.
Like, so I was about to ask her a picture, but she went to
her seat.
So then I was just like, oh, whatever.
Okay, I thought it was like pretty cool.
I was just like, oh my God, I wanted to take a picture and
show it to him.
But then I was just like, whatever.
All right, it's fine.
Missed opportunity.
I wish I did.
It was actually, I was just like, is that Kenny Omega?
like confused because I was like um because like she was
like at the front like talking to like the tenants and stuff
the theater tenants and so so I was just like but I couldn't
tell exactly if that was kenny omega because she had like
other stuff in the eta bag too that wasn't just him so I was
just like oh but but I finally realized it I was just like
it's too late anyway so so anyway I ordered I had a good
time I was also half drunk Okay, wait, so, um, in this
theater, they sell, like, obviously they sell alcohol, but
they put it, there's like, I could have ordered the one
where, um, where it's like, in those, you know, the classic,
uh, the margarita cups or, like, the small ones, but I
ordered the fishbowl drinks.
Wait, let me see, it's fishbowl bowl.
uh alcohol you know the giant ones the okay these this is
the cup i ordered this is where the cup i ordered because i
wanted to order that particular drink and i was ready to
party i was ready so i basically watched project hell mary
like half drunk by myself um guys i was trying to enjoy my
So I was like, I can't wait for my new bed Anyway, so this
is the size of the cup I couldn't guess Do not worry, I did
not drink all of it I did not drink all of this So this is
like basically around the size of the cup And I was just
like, you know what, let's fucking go Let's buy I did not
drink all of it guys It was like, I drank like One fifth of
this It was like a, it was mango flavored.
I was like, I was like so down.
I was so down to go, woo, woo.
Did you, I do remember the, I was not drunk, but I was half
drunk.
It was a good movie.
I'll say I understand the hype of the movie.
The movie was pretty good.
Um, anyway, so I was like, I had a great time being half
drunk, watching the movie, getting ready, home, walk back
home, half drunk.
So, me and you know, I was like, in joy, ready to relax and
get to enjoy the bed.
I was like, what a great way to end the day, you know, what
a great way.
Not sober, getting to sleep on my new comfy ass bed with my
bamboos.
silk bed sheets and my hexagonal pillows the pillows with
the hexagons on them cannot wait came home yeah got ready to
lie down on the bed dad for some reason was not on the bed
thought that was weird he was sleeping in his own bed got
ready and i looked at it and there it was on my fancy bamboo
silk bedsheet.
Dog vomit.
There it was.
It was, let's say it was past midnight.
Almost, almost past midnight.
I never had a chance to try.
the bed up and there it was in less than eight hours of me
owning that bed it now had not only on the bed sheets but
also on the mattress a giant ass yellow stain on my mattress
and bed sheets too because I decided to put on the bedsheets
before I left to see the movie and I was only gone for two
and a half hours guys I was only gone for two and a half
hours so not only have to clean the bedsheets but I had to
clean the mattress too on the first day hasn't even been out
for 24 hours but on the first birthday
anyway so
it was funny the salesman was like oh you want to buy a
protective sheet to cover your mattress and that was like no
it's fine I'm sure it's okay we can buy it later like like I
can buy that later.
I should be fine.
I just want, I don't think I need it.
Like it's just, it's fine.
Because my old mattress didn't have it.
My old mattress didn't have a protective sheet.
So I was just like, what's the worst that could happen?
It's the first, I mean, like, that would be a while until I
need a protective sheet, you know?
And dad's never vomited on or peed on the bed before.
your life cyber dragoon thank you for the akasupa thank you
thank you thank you so much for the akasupa yeah what's the
worst that can happen that's never like my dog's never done
anything to the bed before it you know like what's the worst
that can happen at best it's just drool and stuff you know
like what's the worst that can
oh you know this like this is the worst that can happen and
you know what's the cherry on the cake i like to sleep on
that side i don't sleep like a on the middle like a normal
human being i normally sleep on the left side because it's
further away from the door because it's like is like
training from back in when i like sleep in hotel rooms with
my parents and everything and i always sleep on the furthest
side to the door because if a murderer comes in they'll stab
the person closest to the door so like i will have a chance
i will have like at least five seconds to get out like i
don't know it's something as a kid i've always done that as
a kid like as a kid my parents would be like which side do
you want to sleep on i'll be like on the furthest from the
door so it would be always be on the left side so because so
i was thinking like if anyone breaks in the person that's
closest to the door is first like and i've had that thought
since i was like a little kid because i was just like if
anything if anyone breaks in the person closest to the door
is first so i will always be on the left side
so I always sleep on that side no matter what and then dad
would sleep on the right side because like you know that's
all the space he can have or you'll sleep on top of my legs
so so he vomited on the left side where I sleep on like
legitimately the area that I would putting my entire body
on.
So, yeah.
So, spent last night washing my new bedsheets, which I
shouldn't be washing right now.
Which, I shouldn't have had to wash on day one.
Also, I had to Uber eat hydrogen peroxide because I was like
panic attack like what do I do and I was reading looking up
YouTube tutorials on YouTube shorts being like how do I get
stains off my mattress and everyone's like you should use
hydrogen peroxide so I fucking bought hydrogen peroxide and
and also some microfibers and also also like those like
spray cans to like that spray weekends to like you know do
the smell stuff and everything and and I was I I went to
work I literally went to work I was just like this can't
happen I how do I clean dog vomit at one in the morning Siri
like so so yeah it's gone now I mean it's as gone as it
could be as it can be to buy new tide pods too because I was
running out so the state must be a limit it was the first
day I was not I was going I had to get it out I will stop at
nothing until that shit was gone I was so sad all right all
right so it's there's like just a little bit of the yellow
left like you can see at the center is where the center was
where the impact was you can tell where majority impact was
like so it's just a tiny bit of yellow that's left on there
i couldn't i despite how hard i was scrubbing i couldn't get
that small yellow off like it's like some faded ass yellow
off
it's like the impact zone of where it all happened
oh my god Oh
Anyway, and then I sprayed I guys forget but And then I was
just like I I was done it was I was tired I've wanted I've
wanted to fucking sleep on my new bed
I was really looking forward to it guys I
It's all done I kicked the dog stairs out of my room and I I
was like, never again.
I legitimately, I'm so mad.
I kicked the dog stairs out of my room.
I was like, you're never, you're not allowed up here.
You're on a curfew now.
That's what you, yeah.
You're gonna be a ground dog.
No more bed privileges.
He's grounded now.
And, and, um, uh yeah now he sleeps on the floor like a
fucking peasant yeah no more bed privileges anyway so got my
new bed it's great it's a great bed it's just very despite
everything that happened um it's very comfy like
legitimately i had a really good time in my new comfy bed oh
i love i love the bed frame guys it has storage space i was
i got know i know it's like guys no you won't believe it the
bed frame i has drawers it's great i could put stuff in the
drawers in the bed frame um but yes i learned about off
gassing that day too i didn't realize i could smell a little
i could smell a bit of it i didn't realize that it had such
a huge effect on animals, because I would have kicked the
door, I would have kicked the bed stairs, um, I would have
kicked it off like, before I went to the theaters.
If I knew, if I knew, I would have kicked the stairs out
before he fucking get, before he could even get on the bed.
Um, it's his revenge for like his hiding place thank you the
super chat mill thank you thank you i lacked critical info
um anyway so that's story time for today um all right today
uh we are gonna be playing heroes of might and magic three
so i've always been looking for it to no the bed people did
not tell me this all they said was you got not you can't
sleep on the bed for two to three hours That's all the
information they gave me.
I guess they assumed that this is not my first time buying a
bed, but this was literally my first time buying a bed for
myself.
Like, I've never had that experience before.
Never had, like, done any of this before.
So I guess they assumed that I had lots of experience.
And I feel like if they saw my old mattress, they should
know that this was definitely not my first experience for
how long I kept that mattress.
It's literally my first rodeo.
Anyway, so.
I've always wanted to play this game on stream.
Because this is one of my childhood games.
If you guys ever see my debut streams or whatever, where
we'd be like, your favorite game.
Who's that?
I put Heroes of Metamagic 3.
This game was a hand-me-down from my dad growing up.
lot of the games that I grew up playing grew up growing up
was my dad giving me giving it to me as a hand me down so
like you know you after he was done playing on it he would
just give me his game so that's how I grew up playing
Starcraft and Heroes of Might and Magic and all that stuff
because those were the games that my dad gave me to play I
think those were like the two PC games that he gave me um
anyway and then uh so I've always wanted to play this game
um on stream for a time, but I was always very hesitant
because it's not like the type of games that I usually play
on this channel.
It's also a very, very old game.
Here's a Mighty Magic 3 is my favorite version.
I mean, it's the one that my dad gave me, so it's always
been my favorite.
And I used to play this game a lot growing up.
Like I, when I was little, I always like replay it a lot.
Same with Starcraft.
And, uh, but the thing is, I always cheated in the game.
So did my dad.
because it's very hard because I was like a little kid guys
I was like a very little kid I did not know what the fuck I
was doing so my dad he would give me a piece he would have
like a piece of paper of all the cheats written down like
the angels cheat like because I don't know how he got these
cheats I obviously he must have got it on the internet but
back then I was like oh my god the game you know he has like
i was like oh my god i he must have known somebody he had
like it was same with starcraft he also cheated on starcraft
a lot too and then i you know he would give me like the hat
like the the the sacred text uh when he handed me the game
when it was like a had me down um when he had me the game he
also handed me the sacred text of starcraft and um um a
heroes of might and magic so you know like starcraft would
like fog of war and all that like unlimited resources and
stuff so i also cheated in starcraft as well because you
know he cheated too so it's like mutual cheating uh it was
how i was taught guys you know i was like nurture versus
nature i was nurtured into this um yeah show me the money in
fog of war anyway so um When he handed me down the Heroes of
Might and Magic 3, he also handed me the sacred text on how
to win Heroes of Might and Magic.
So he'd be like, if you're ever in trouble, just use these
codes and then you'll be able to win the game.
And then, so I would always spam.
I would always spam the angels because that's what I saw my
dad doing because I would watch him play.
And I was like, oh, it's so fun.
I want to play too.
He'll be like, when I'm done with it, you can play this
game.
angels cheat where his entire team he would have like two or
three units that like are from his own faction and the rest
would be like 20 angels he'll have like 10 to 20 angels and
then just so you can beat the game um yeah i was like oh my
god i'm gonna do that too and uh so um yeah so you know when
he handed it to me because like you would get default five
for those who don't know the archangels default wise is five
but then he would spam the cheat until he gets like 10 to 20
because he's yeah 10 to 20 angels per unit by the way it's
like per unit it'll be 10 to 20 because you can spam it
because it adds five every time you use it um next thing
thank you the super chat thank you thank you that explains
so much about why you are the way you are thank you for the
super yeah why stop at five exactly why stop so anyway um
anyway uh what happened was that uh was that i never beat
the game legit i never beat a level legit you know i was a
kid i didn't know what the fuck i was doing i barely read so
i didn't know but had a great time.
I honestly, great memories.
I love playing that game, but I've never beat the game legit
legitimately.
So, um, not a single level, not a single level legitimately.
I would always default into one or two of the cheats.
And so, you know, at the ending, whenever you beat the
level, it just says cheater.
And I was just like, what does that mean?
I was so I'll just say, I beat the game!
And then on the screen, it'll be like, cheater.
But I'll be like, yeah!
It's that way!
I wonder what it could mean.
Because that's the end credits.
If you beat the game on any of the campaigns, it literally,
like, you'll get the dragon credits.
You'll get the dragon.
but then instead of like that your stats and everything it's
just cheater like they'll know you that because you use the
cheat codes so it won't give you any of your stats or like
how how well you did and everything it literally just says
cheater um but yeah anyway so i've always wanted to play
this game again i haven't played it in a long time It was
really funny because if guys weren't in the chat, in the
offline chat, I was trying to figure out how to log on to
Gog because apparently the HD version is not as good as the
original.
Apparently, I don't know.
I just read on Steam.
People were like, don't get it.
Buy the one on Gog.
So I was like, I'll just buy the one on Gog.
I was trying to figure out which account.
I apparently had two accounts and I didn't even realize.
I thought I only had one because I bought Silkson on it and
I, for some reason, my Chrome, my browser, was, um, had only
the records for my old Gogg account.
And I was like, I have an old Gogg account?
I was so confused.
I was like, when did I have, when did I have the Gogg
account?
Yeah.
NSD, thank you for sending, uh, the one gifted ship.
Thank you.
And Sam, thank you for sending a gifted ship.
Oh, is there an HD patch?
Okay, wait which one's the hd patch i just have okay anyway
i'll continue the story so um i was trying to figure out i
was trying to buy it but it wouldn't let me buy it and i
realized the reason why it wouldn't let me buy it was
because i actually already own the game i already owned the
game and i was so confused i was just like when did i when
did i buy this game i do not remember buying this game but
apparently pat's turkey bought this game years ago and it
was the only game on that account it was literally only um
only game on my old god account nothing else it was just
heroes of might and magic and i have no idea when she bought
this game i think i can find it let me see i'm pretty sure i
can find it let's see do i have it okay heroes oh my god it
doesn't even show and oh my god in 2016 I bought this game
in 2016 holy shit wait a minute yeah that's how long ago 10
years ago past Doki bought heroes of might and magic 10
years ago and I never played it I never I never touched it
Literally 10 years ago, I created a Gog account and I don't
even, I didn't even touch it.
I even touched the game after I bought it.
I was just like, oh my god, I think it was like, I was like,
oh my god, I remember this game.
Oh my god, that's my childhood.
And I bought it and I didn't touch it.
And she knew, she knew I will become a streamer and she knew
I'll become a streamer.
And I was going to play this on stream one day.
she did if she was she predicted it in the future she made
an investment for me a future investment and yeah i actually
made another account wait let's see i made a another account
for on because you can you can also create an account via
discord and then the discord one is the one where i bought
silk song but let me hide this real quick i'll show you guys
this that's created i can't even 10 years ago that's insane
i did not expect 10 years ago i would i had bought this game
because i was so confused i was like why can't i buy it oh i
already owned this when the fuck did i buy owned this game i
do not remember but past yokey remembers all right here is
proof oops okay here is proof that i used to Owned this
game.
I'm trying to save it right now, guys.
Give me a sec.
You can see the date of purchase and everything.
All right, let me save it real quick.
Here you guys.
My receipts, she knew.
She could tell.
Look at that.
She knew.
The date of purchase.
2016.
May 3rd Almost Almost exactly 10 years ago Oh my god What
else did she buy?
What else did she hide from me?
That's actually insane I think it was exactly when they put
this game Maybe this I think it was when they put this game
on Gog too It was We're told.
Oh my god.
Does she know?
She was on to something there.
She was playing 5D.
That's my Bitcoin.
There's only 10 billion Bitcoin right there.
I bought one Bitcoin 10 years ago.
And now I'm a millionaire.
She knew.
I thought it was crazy.
crazy i was just like oh my god 10 years ago uh but yeah
anyway uh i love this game i know like you know even despite
never completing the game legitimately on any level i still
really like this game um i i have tried i remember when as i
got older and i replayed it the game as i was getting older
um still a little kid by the way still a little kid it'll be
like two to three years later and then i was like you know
i'm gonna try doing legitimately i'll do it legitimately
i'll wait till like i was about to die and i was like i
don't want to lose i was like i've never lose and then i you
know i would try to do it legitimately and then at any at
any point i felt like i was about to lose i like archangels
archangels archangels never surrender so i would have you
know legit team and then archangels
emergency nick and then never completed a level legitimately
because i did not want to admit defeat i was like i'm not
letting ai kill me i'm not letting ai win guys we let ai win
what else are we gonna that happen when will we stop if we
let ai win let exactly never let them win cheater
I can't let them win guys if I let them win they'll think
they're better than us then they'll take over the world all
right let's see all right let me get apparently I should
install the HD mod I know there's like apparently there's a
new there's like an extra DLC like a fan mod where they
added new towns and new But I do want to enjoy it, like, as
it was, because that's what I grew up on.
So I like, I want to do, like, you know, I want to play the
characters that I grew up on, the towns that I know.
I'll maybe look into the other towns at another point, but I
do want to, I want to experience it as it was when I was
growing up.
Yeah, I want to do, experience the nostalgia.
Death before Dysonic Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, let's see.
How do I search?
Is this the HD mod?
HD mod.
I'm trying to find it.
Where is the HD mod?
How do I get it?
How do I activate the HD mod?
I don't use Gog as often.
Oh yeah, let me...
Swap real quick Um Oh, wait, do you have to Oh, it includes
the HD mod?
Oh, wait.
Is it like in Gogg, or do you have to like patch it?
Are you a fan of my Lord and Savior of the stronghold town,
Stair?
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jacob, thank you, the super chat.
Face taste turkey.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
I love my gaming Early gaming taste was based off my dad So
he was the one that introduced me to a lot of the games that
I enjoy Oh, is it?
Oh, okay Okay, my magic 3 HD mod I didn't even realize that
HD mod Gogg Oh my god, everybody is like Gogg I used to have
complete this game is all nice I remember our complete just
launched the installer and includes HD mod.
Installing is not corrupt, so you can usually run...
Oh, okay.
I'll download this.
H-O-M-M-H-D.
Download.
Alright.
I'm installing it.
And he never got into Halo because he was like, fuck Xbox!
Sony only!
PlayStation for life!
And also he was like, you want a Nintendo console just for
babies?
Are you a baby?
And I'm like, yes, I'm a baby.
He's like, no, you're not!
luckily he let me have like he let me have uh you know game
boys and stuff because it was like a handheld so but like
console wise i was not allowed to have anything outside of
playstation because he's like you know it was his
playstation like that's only only in this house yeah so
because you know the consoles were his so he's like he buys
the con he's like what am i gonna play on Nintendo consoles.
Oh, Doki, what am I gonna play?
I was like, oh, I just want to play Animal Crossing.
I didn't even get PSP.
My dad got the PSP.
My mom was like, I got a present for your dad.
It's a PSP.
I was like, I don't have a PSP.
I don't even have a PSP.
Okay.
Must be installed It's not, okay, I need to find heroes of
might and magic.
Where the fuck is the fool there for this?
I mean, I told a story before, but when I was a little kid,
my dad would make me watch him play the Resident Evil game
with Nemesis, and that traumatized me.
I literally could not sleep.
Like, I was way too young to, like, fucking watch that.
And he's like, it's time I'm going to play Resident Evil.
He would, like, bring me up to his bed, Like, I'll just sit
there watching him play.
And he's like, well, what do I don't want to want?
He's like, nope, you're going to watch me play Resident
Evil.
And then I had nightmares from Resident Evil.
All right, let's see.
I'm trying to, like, I remember the glass, like, I, I, I
remember the scene where, I don't know, it was a nemesis.
He would break through the glass and it would be thunder.
Like, bada-bomb.
And he breaks through the window or something.
And that's all I remember from Resident Evil 3.
And that traumatized me, because I would always, like, in my
dreams, I would always see him.
Like, in my dreams, I'd see Nemesis in my dreams.
Stars, that chair, I assume.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
But I was way, guys, I was way too young to see that.
It might have been super cool, but I was a little kid And
also Resident Evil 4 I saw my dad played Resident Evil 4 too
growing up and I was way too young for that as well I saw
him play Resident Evil 4 like five different four like maybe
four different times Because they kept re-releasing Resident
Evil 4 I didn't know I was raising a fucking baby.
I was like I'm a baby baby, though, Dad.
But I am a baby.
Yeah.
Anyway, here's a minor magic.
I just downloaded the HD pass.
That's why I'm scared of horror films or, like, horror games
in general.
I got traumatized very young about horror games.
That's why I don't fuck with horror games.
I had to grow up by watching my dad play horror games.
I'm trying to remember what other game.
I just, most of the time, oh, and also Call of Duty.
And was it called the...
Where are the...
All the Modern Warfare, Call of Duty, all of them.
My dad loved the war games.
What was the other one?
The old one?
Medal of Honor?
Medal of Honor, Call of Duty slash Modern Warfare.
Medal of Honor was so old.
I'm just remembering it.
I watched my dad play that.
Battlefield.
Was it Medal of Honor game?
Yeah.
Medal of Honor.
He would play Medal of Honor.
Battlefield, Call of Duty, all those games growing up.
I watched him play GTA and stuff.
He loved GTA.
I remember watching him play GTA when I was young and
everything.
Yeah, so he played all of those games.
I remember playing World of Warcraft.
RTS version.
Oh, that too.
I also grew up with the RTS World of Warcraft game as well,
growing up.
So I remember that was also another hand-me-down game-y, but
I didn't like it as much as StarCraft, because I was just
like, I was so confused with the lore and everything.
Like, StarCraft was easy.
It was like, Alien Bad.
Yeah, Warcraft 3.
Yeah, sorry, Worldcraft 3.
Um, like, StarCraft was easy for me to digest, because it
was like, Alien Bad.
This is a, and then that is badder than that alien and then
when he gave me Warcraft 3 I was like what the fuck is going
on I was like too young to understand anything I was just
like I remember I was trying to play Warcraft 3 I was like I
don't understand like I I don't understand the lore or like
the story I'm in and then the the hero design the hero
design for Warcraft 3 was not was not as good as StarCraft
I'm sorry like the character design for it like I was like
as a kid I was like you I was like you're nice pretty you
know because I was a kid I looked at design wise I was like
you're not a cool the warcraft characters don't look as cool
as the starcraft characters so um so that's why i never
never got into uh warcraft 3 back then i really got into
starcraft though because i really love the character designs
and everything because i love you know i love the zerg race
and that's why I loved Heroes of Mind and Magic because the
character designs, the unit designs were so cool.
And I was like, oh, they're so cool.
I hated playing.
You know, I didn't, I never played the humans on any of the
games.
I like playing the monsters and the creatures because I
thought the designs were so fucking cool.
So I didn't like the Warcraft 3 designs because I was just
like, even though like there's not a lot of human designs in
there too, I just thought the Preacher designs weren't as
cool as Starcraft or Heroes of Might and Magic because the
human same with Lord of the Rings Like I said, I played the
Lord of the Rings RTS too That was also my dad's had me
down.
I just remembered Lord like my dad loved RTS and I also
played Age of Empires when I was growing up as well Like my
dad was a huge RTS fan.
So I played a lot of RTS growing up and you know, I remember
was it Red Alert the one with the Yeah, like he played Red
Alert age of Empires um uh the lord of the rings one and uh
i i never liked i i remember playing a little bit of red
alert but i wasn't like super into red alert um and then but
i love the lord of rings uh rts um and uh i was a huge fan
of of you know of playing like soron's race like soron's
faction because like i like i said i love the creature
design i didn't give a about the elves are the humans
because I was just like it's just humans with ears like with
pointy ears I was just like you're not as cool where am I I
get to ride I was like who wants to ride a horse where I can
ride a wolf yeah I was like who cares about John Eagle I can
ride a dragon who the fuck wants to ride a horse that's so
plain that's so normie that's so fucking basic i can ride up
john ass wolf yeah and i can ride spiders too
so i was like more into i was more into like you know the
creature designs and stuff because i thought it was just
much more interesting um oh sorry i've been yapping sorry
now it's for real heroes of mighta magic for real play sorry
guys Hey, you have to die.
All right, please install this.
They were so cool.
It was so fucking cool.
All right, I need to install something apparently.
Because they were like, you got to install this so you can
boot up the HD feature.
And I hope I'm not installing malware.
All right, wait, actually, that's not what we wanted.
This size.
Oh my god!
Oh, the nostalgia is hitting already!
Is it this?
Oh my god, the nostalgia is hitting right now.
Wait, I need to save...
Oh, the soundtrack!
All right, let me see.
What is this?
This is for Lego.
I need a...
I'm trying, guys.
I don't know why it's not capturing.
That is the launcher, right?
Heroes of Minor Magic 3.
Oh, don't tell me.
It can't be captured or some shit.
Okay, give me a sec.
I think it's one of those things.
Okay, full screen mode.
All right, I'm going to do full screen mode.
Max, yeah, full screen mode.
And then, oh, don't create a shortcut.
All right, play.
Is this it?
Oh, 3DO.
New world computing.
I know you guys don't see it right now.
But have you seen a new Luna?
Yeah, I have.
I like how it was like creature update.
And there's like, here's Luna with a car.
Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sorry, I'm trying, I'm trying, guys.
I'm trying to capture it.
I might have to do a window capture or something.
Ah, yeah, this is a window capture game.
I can see it.
All right, let me, let me fix this real quick.
It's a window capture game.
Yeah, yeah, I knew it.
Okay, uh, reset transform.
There we go.
You want me to boot it again so we can go back to nostalgia.
I'll do it.
You want to see it again?
Just to get that nostalgia hit.
One more time, Doki, please.
Inject that nostalgia into my into my veins.
I need another hit.
3DO.
Oh my god, the nostalgia.
Oh
my god, I love the size.
I love the song.
I love that song.
Oh, I love it.
Okay.
Single scenario.
Do we do campaign or?
Oh my god.
Armageddon's blade.
Restoration of Irrigation.
see a shadow of death.
Oh my god.
Do you remember?
I remember.
Oh my god.
I always I always love playing spoilers of war.
I would replay this particular campaign over and over again
because I love I love this class, this faction.
This is one of my favorite factions.
could campaign so many times sleeping thank you my super
chat thank you thank you because this was my favorite one of
my favorite factions the game is older than a lot of people
here official unc saddest duck thank you the super chat
thank you thank you thank you that this really 3d is my o's
right now sorry thank you the super chat thank you thank you
all right let me see you sound guy let me know let me know
if sounds okay i need like tab out because it the sound
sending pauses whenever Ah, spoilers of war.
I don't know which campaign to start with.
I didn't like the snow one.
I don't want to play the humans.
Gova, thank you for the 20 gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Aphelia, thank you for the five gifted ships.
All right, what campaign should I start?
Do I go straight from the beginning?
New beginning?
Or do we play spoilers of war?
Well, I don't even...
The thing is, I did not process the story.
I need you guys to know, I was not processing the story.
Oh, I just wanted to win when I was little.
I didn't even know what, I didn't really know what the story
was.
So I'll be experiencing the story for the first time.
I just clicked.
bigger screen to play with.
Oh, I did change it.
I put it at 1920 X1080.
So it should have started it.
Yeah, this was, I think when we launched it, maybe?
Because when I launched it, I put it at a bigger resolution.
Alright, we'll do spoilers of war.
In this time to strike, your mercenaries will earn you great
rewards.
With Erethia collapsing under the weight of an onslaught in
the east property where some land grabbing has presented
itself in the west to win uh oh bring down the volume
overall all right i'll do that let me know the if it's
better oh i can change it in game after you launch oh okay
wait let's change it in game how do i change it all right i
just have new game oh maybe it's like the game is that what
you mean all right you must flag all my oh yeah by the way i
didn't understand that there's like scenario winnings like
how um how you have to win i thought i thought to win is
just kill everything so what in certain campaigns i got
stuck and i was like so frustrated at the win conditions so
i was just my win condition was to kill everything so i was
in some of the campaigns, because I was like, why am I not
winning?
Yeah, I was just like, why am I not winning?
Everyone's dead.
But they're like, must I go to mine?
So I was like, oh.
I was like, maybe I just didn't have enough angels.
Maybe I should start killing more.
Yeah.
I was like, what do you mean?
Like, I don't understand.
Why am I not winning?
Like, I don't dead okay i need to be uneasy this is as you
foresaw my lord king griffin heart's death brings many
opportunities for your mercenary skills a messenger from
titalia on behalf of king trelosk has contacted us 20 years
ago following numerous border skirmishes along the western
shore of erathia titalia signed an agreement to cease
hostilities king griffin heart is dead their agreement has
died with him oh no aggressive tactics have never been part
of Yeah, I even lit like fog, like the fog thing.
Just so I could be like, what am I missing?
They're all dead.
To expand their borders and accommodate their growing
population.
All right, we need to flag all the mines.
This first order from King Tasterlock or seize all mines in
the region so that the armies of Tattalia will have the
resources necessary for a larger military campaign.
But there is good news and bad news.
The good news is that the three Erethian outposts in the
area are mostly depleted due to the war in the east.
The bad news is that they can summon reinforcements faster
than we can.
So we must act quickly.
This is one of my favorite factions.
I just love the creature designs.
The plot just occurred to me.
But would it be appropriate to suggest the Doki Bit model
for the super boomerang in the future?
Oh, that is a good idea.
Maybe in the future for sure.
Metti, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's already too late.
Then you'll be able to complete your contract at your
leisure.
And...
Beautiful.
Good!
Experience!
Get that!
And then this.
Okay, and then... Oh, I have two talents.
That's always nice.
Oh, I love this music.
I like this music too.
And that's why... That's why I really liked this faction
too.
Boom.
Serpent!
We gotta get serpent.
I'm gonna grab the serpent and fly, huh?
Because I love these guys.
These guys are funny.
I like them because they're funny.
I don't know.
I forgot which one generates more money.
It doesn't even...
Oh, wait.
Okay, I'll go for this.
Year of Defense.
Okay, increase production.
You can buy and sell resources.
Allow visiting to learn spells kept within.
Browse your armies with...
Provide your armies with first aid kit.
Okay, we gotta grab the Citadel first.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I don't need another hero yet.
We gotta Gab and Archer.
Okay, we gotta grab wood.
How many?
Lots of them.
Okay, we might not be good.
Let's get armor.
Um...
Digging?
Okay.
I didn't even realize you can dig.
Okay, let's grab...
Rocks, too.
Town hall?
Okay.
Oh, I guess.
Yeah, the gold.
We need town hall, actually.
Okay.
And then...
Let's get another town hall here so we can have more gold.
Alright.
I feel like maybe I should grab another hero so I can
explore longer.
Day three.
Oh, nice!
Actually, Let's yonk, yonk, and then grab the rock, and then
we'll grab, uh, I love the basilics.
Okay, I'm gonna grab the basilics.
We'll grab these guys, too.
And then we'll hire another guy.
Just so we, yeah, I need several heroes.
Okay.
uh he has four oh but oh wait oh but he has the harpy ladies
so specialties gorgon ah but he has the cool harpies also i
love this class too this one was one of my other favorite
factions as well um that's a bear that's that's a bear
that's not a dog i need i should hire him just because he's
like part of my faction it wouldn't make sense
I could get a dragon okay wait let's look at the other stuff
first betting against not production per six days I'm
getting a dragon I'm getting whivered.
All right, let's grab all these mats.
Oh, no.
Here we have this.
Where are the mines?
I don't remember what the mines look like.
What the fuck?
Oh, that's my save.
Oh, it's a...
Oh, the thing!
Oh, try again.
tomorrow.
Alright, what about you?
Grab everything!
That flagged one?
Oh, wait, that's the mine!
Oh, wait, no, that's the ore pit.
Is that...
Is that the mines?
That has to be the mines.
I can win this.
Oh, wait, that's a pack of...
I should be able to.
That guy looks weak.
Oh, I can upgrade.
Alright, we'll upgrade the...
I'm gonna upgrade the Citadel, actually.
Same with...
Let's make the castle bigger!
Don't want to make sure I have everything.
Oh, shit.
There he is.
Wait, do I have enough?
I have 50!
Let's go!
Yay!
All right.
Just four.
A glorious victory.
Get over here.
Don't worry, I have so much money.
It should be fine.
Yay!
A glorious victory!
Money!
Experience!
Uh...
You know what?
Wait, what is this?
A hero contributes 1 to 25.
You know what?
Offence.
A good offense is a good defense.
There's no battle.
Oh, wait, is it automatic?
I thought it was like, oh.
Where is it?
I thought it was on...
Wasn't it automatic if it's like...
If it's a guarantee win?
Yeah.
What?
That is auto battle.
I thought it was like guarantee win.
Where is auto battle?
How do I turn it off?
Yeah.
Apply results just say no.
Where is it?
Oh, is it quick combat?
Oh, there it is.
Alright, there you go.
Hero speed, enemy speed.
Hi, please.
Alright.
That...
Visit that already.
I don't remember.
That's so much money And I can have even more money.
Okay, I need wait mage guild level one marketplace Okay,
let's grab that We'll grab that Oh mage guild Did I grab
this right?
No, I didn't I got I got that I Let's get the Swan Pond,
too.
Oh, let's kill him.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I gotta zoom.
Wee!
Oh, shit.
Don't worry, you live!
Kill him!
Oh, shit.
He might be dead.
It's okay.
Believe in the dragonfly.
There we go.
There's 41 of me.
All right, it's okay.
It's okay.
I can recruit more, guys.
Okay, advance.
Reduces the movement penalty.
Increases the damage done, but we don't have any archers
yet, so let's not do that.
All right, let's get the fountain of youth.
How many do I have?
2019?
That should be fine.
Yes!
Join my army!
All right.
All right, we must continue building!
Okay, marketplace.
Wait, do I have...
Can I recruit more people, right?
Not yet.
Okay, marketplace.
Oh, yeah, zero available right now.
All right, let's grab experience.
You know what?
Magic!
Alright.
Grant me luck!
I demand the luck!
Yeah, I need all that money.
And then I got more luck.
Ooh, can I kill them?
I should be fine.
Oh!
I should...
Oh shit, he's getting closer.
Oh, bring the game down a little bit.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me bring the game down a little bit.
It should be fine, right?
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
Oh, shit.
Do I bravely run away?
Oh, okay.
Okay, there is still hope.
Oh, oh.
Okay, we might have to bravely run away.
We got...
All right, and we bravely...
Oh, my God, what happened to him?
He did...
Guys, I think it's time for...
It might be time for Angel.
I thought he ran away!
Where did he go?
Retrieve!
I thought I was so strong!
It's okay, he's back.
Yeah, he's easy.
He's like, he never left.
Okay, you stay here.
Actually, you can explore a little bit.
We bravely ran away.
Very bravely.
We were so brave.
Okay, Increase is a hero.
We gotta grab that.
How was I supposed to know when they said lots of Gorgons?
That didn't be a lot of Gorgons.
How could I have known?
Guys, how could I have known that?
Brave, sir.
Exactly.
It takes a lot of courage to run around so bravely.
We'll grab money just in case.
Okay, now that I know the Gorgons are pretty strong, we do
not fuck with them.
We shall no longer fuck with the Gorgons.
Oh my god.
You mean there's a lot of Gorgons?
No fucking way.
Okay, requires a castle.
We'll build that.
So we can build a better town hall.
We're not at $5,000.
Oh, I don't.
In my treasury.
Okay.
We'll grab a serpent fly hive.
Oh, there he is.
He thinks he's so good.
He thinks he's better than me.
Well, I'll show him.
I'll show them.
I'll show them all.
Okay.
But there is a lizard den here.
Wait, actually, let me get more people real quick.
I'll show them all.
They'll regret the day.
Okay.
We'll upgrade.
We're going to lizard den.
So we have archers.
Okay.
Okay, we have no money in this town right now.
Don't worry.
I'm coming back with money, guys.
All right.
We'll grab Gorgons, too.
We'll show them.
Also, let me know the sounds better.
The music is better.
If it's too loud or too quiet.
It was too loud last time, right?
I'm sorry, I didn't realize the game was so loud.
I hope you guys were able to hear me earlier.
I'll grab some of the...
Yeah, last time earlier.
I was a bit too loud.
I didn't realize.
my god i'm too broke i'm too no i'm so poor who would have
thought that spent too much money all by the power beginning
you wish no just leave i need more money
uh just a little drown out before i'm so sorry i was so
passionate about this game I didn't realize oh my god I'm
broke I kept building I couldn't help it all I wanted to do
was build I haven't visited that we should visit that we'll
fight him oh no get out of here don't Don't fight me.
That's right.
Do I still...
Wait, I've got money again.
I will hire this.
And then we'll got the Gorgons too.
That's right.
We signed them up.
Anyway, let's buy more stuff.
Wait, I gotta save.
I should save money so I can earn more money.
Alright.
Let's start recruiting people, though.
This one is...
This place...
This town is fucked.
We've...
taxed everybody.
So there's nothing we can do.
Alright.
Out there.
Yay!
Yeah, join my army.
I shall spread word to me to Borgard that you're allowed to
pass.
Oh, I can pass this now.
Oh my god, there is a pack of these guys.
Uh...
I do want to grab this before I go.
And trade resources for gold?
No!
I actually don't have a lot of resources either, so I'm
saving money.
I don't have a lot of resources, so I don't think I should.
Although I said saving money, but I started recruiting
people.
I should save my money, for real, is that?
For real.
Now I save my money.
Here we are, visit this.
Oh, do I have to revisit this?
Is it everything because I fucking died?
I didn't realize that.
I should hire more.
Oh, am I on day seven?
Oh, I'm on day seven.
How much money do I need?
I'm so close.
All right, let's hire another hero.
All right.
All right, we'll get Girl Wolf.
Because he's also a...
Actually...
specialty
Yeah, I was thinking that I was thinking of getting that so
I could pick up the guy
No one necromancer another beast master but I don't know but
I don't know no no oh wait can't bring down oh wait no All
right, we brought down the music a little bit
All right, we'll grab another beast master we'll upgrade you
It's only $320.
Oh, melee.
Let's grab this.
And grab the watermill, too.
And then...
I think we can take this guy on.
We have 38.
It should be fine.
What's the worst that can happen?
What's the worst that can happen, guys?
Everything will be fine.
What could go wrong?
All right.
Begin the scatter.
Why won't you join me?
All right, get them in here.
Join my army.
Wait, how many?
I have 38.
Oh, shit.
It's all right.
He's got this!
He's so healthy.
One hit and it's over.
Oh, it was not one hit.
Okay, one hit and it's over.
Don't worry, he lives.
Look at that.
Oh, don't worry.
I told one hit and it'll be over.
I told you!
One hit and it'll be over.
Do I have enough now?
I'm almost there.
I don't want to recruit anything.
I should get the ballistic to the other guy.
How do I give it to him?
Let's see.
Oh, I'm just surrounded by things.
Oh, they all block my...
way I have nothing else to explore the Gorgons they're too
strong let's
just keep we'll go all in on him yes join my army all right
all in on that one guy
oh all right we gotta have our one guy to create a path for
everybody it ain't looking so good right now angel time he's
he's gonna chill he's done his job oh wait i have enough
it's time more money all right now i'm broke again
all right you're my chosen one okay well we'll We will...
We will...
We'll attack him.
Or should we get more luck?
Actually, we'll attack him.
And then you...
I guess you can grab...
visit that.
Yeah!
Alright, uh...
Well, these guys are used to listen to me now so uh they're
sort of trapped here uh i don't know what to do without any
of you guys now uh oh there he is they're sort of useless
because i have nothing i guess uh just get the water mill
real quick just get get resources for me guys all right i'm
broke right now i forgot what it was like to not have money
in this game i'm so used to having so much money we'll just
keep killing yes join me talk he lives tells you the place
is near and far with me which may aid your oh oh oh he has
so Wait.
Oh, God.
He has a horde?
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I could.
I got the Gorgons.
I got the flies.
Okay, okay.
It's possible.
It's angel time.
Wait, guys, guys, guys.
We can turn this around.
Oh, we can turn this around, guys.
We can do this.
Okay.
I just need more people.
I just need to kill more.
If we kill more, we can turn this around.
Wait.
We'll grab our army here.
There we go.
Yes.
And then, oh my god.
Can I even upgrade these?
Oh, I don't even have...
Watch this.
Boom!
We have a hundred!
Oh my god, we're so strong.
I can kill him.
Guys, I can kill him.
It's possible.
Alright.
I should be able to take this over this now.
But I could recruit him.
Okay.
I'll recruit one of these.
I'm going to recruit get all of this and then take over here
and then kill him and then take his house
It'll be fine.
Oh my gosh, I need to learn magic.
I almost forgot about magic
Okay, advanced artillery artillery Okay, actually I would I
should get that I'm at home invasion That's right, I'm
coming for you!
I'm coming for you!
See, but when I open, I'm coming for you, he knows.
How do you forget magic?
It's half the title.
Don't worry, I know magic now, it's over for him.
I have the high ground.
Okay, we gotta, do we have enough?
We do.
I'm gonna grab money here.
So I can earn more money.
Okay, let me see.
I could grab the upgrade, too.
How many basilisks do I have?
Oh, grab...
Grab a lizard den upgrade.
And then...
Do I not have enough money?
Oh, I don't.
There we go.
Okay.
And then...
Because I want to upgrade some of these guys.
How much can I upgrade?
How much do I have?
We'll keep that here.
Alright.
I'm coming over!
That's right!
Oh, that's right.
Get infected!
Oh!
I can't use my magic yet.
Wait.
Get magic!
Time for what?
Oh, what you gotta do?
This is my town.
I'm coming over.
You're so fucked.
Look at them all.
Slowly walking over.
That's right.
You're going to shake my fly?
I shake you back.
Alright, let's go.
Fuck it.
No, it's alright.
I'm tummy over.
I'm going to take your house.
Get over here.
I'm ready.
I'm going to take your house.
I'm so ready.
All right, let's see.
I'm broke.
So, can't do anything.
Oh, he came back to his house.
All right, that's awkward.
That's awkward.
You can't just walk back to your home.
You can't just do that.
He just walked back home.
That's it.
I'm taking your crystals then.
Yoink.
You gotta leave your house someday.
You can't stay there all day.
I'm waiting for you outside.
Kick his ass.
I'll take your stuff then.
Let's see.
Do I need more wood and ore?
I might as well.
Wait, I can recruit more people right now.
Yeah, I might as well.
I
can't believe he just walked back home
That's fucking oh my god and he's still there He's not
leaving
He's not even leaving That's it Get out of here this is my
town
I'm gonna grab your water mill too.
Fuck you and your water mill.
Just attack.
That's it.
I'm storming the castle.
85?
I'm fucking killing your Griffin.
What do you mean, 85?
Alright.
That's it.
Magic!
Oh, shit.
Wrong one.
Okay.
I'm slowly walking over.
I'm slowly walking.
I should have went for the archer, actually.
That was not the right move.
Oh my god, he magiced me?
That's it.
Archer!
Uh, okay, I'm with the swordsman.
Oh, never mind.
That's okay, I can upgrade him later.
I'm coming over very slow and steady.
Okay.
all right you can do magic uh i can too boom oh all right oh
he's stoned now oh the cow's coming the cow's coming there
we go get out of here what the fuck that's fucking right i
lost 50 men there 50 good men get your ass out of here and
level three spells reduces all damage inflicted against the
heroes troops by 15 percent i'll do that mine now yoink i
told you i'd be back i told you oh my god you got nothing i
can't build this structure what's the point
i can't even own you 50 good men died for me, exactly.
That's it.
I'm going to learn more magic.
I'll recruit more.
That's right.
I got your home.
It's mine now.
I should actually recruit more people in here.
But I'm so broke right now.
Like, this guy, all he does is just farm these resources for
me.
And that's it.
I have no money.
I actually have no money.
Wait, I mean, I could just grab these guys.
And maybe I can kill?
Maybe?
Maybe I can't kill him, that's for sure.
I could kill him.
We'll grab these guys, maybe.
A strange eye turns to studies use as your approach.
After...
Oh, yeah.
Sound guy, is it better now?
At a few moments, it returns to a slow scan of the air.
You can't help but feel like someone or something is using
this eye to spy on you.
on you.
All right.
We don't need a guardsman, honestly.
Kill him.
No, it's fine.
Get out of here.
I need your resources.
At least I can tax them, I guess.
At least, I guess.
All right.
I should be able to kill him.
Yeah.
Now I can actually get other resources, finally.
Oh.
Basic resistance, advanced artillery.
Let's get the artillery.
Oh, I should have got the money!
Because I'm broke!
Oh, I'm so scared of the Gorgons, guys.
I'm actually...
I'm so scared of the Gorgons.
I don't trust them.
What am I supposed to do with this house?
I got nothing.
This house sucks.
All I can do is tax them.
That's all I can do.
All I can do is just tax these people.
That's it.
And they get more every week.
It gives you money, though.
Yoki, if you get more houses, you can tax more people.
Oh my god, you're so right.
I can tax.
more people.
You're so right.
I need more so I can tax more.
Alright.
I don't think I need to... I'm just going to save money.
I don't want to build stuff on this area.
I could grab more people so he could also explore more.
Oh, let's grab it.
Just so he can also... The other guy can also explore.
Why is it?
They have three now?
We're going to grab more gold.
No.
I need money right now.
We'll grab this.
Uh, ah, fine.
Someone worthy.
I shall send word of media to the border guards to let you
patrol.
Alright, nice.
I'm coming for you.
Oh, shit!
Wow, what if I take his house?
Okay.
That's fine.
I can take his house too.
I shall take your house as well.
Uh...
All prerequisites that have been met.
Oh, I just need more wood.
I need more wood here, too.
Uh, let's not build anything.
We'll just chill.
That's why I'm coming over.
Oh, fuck, that little bitch.
That coward.
That fucking coward.
He saw.
Yes, join me.
I didn't kill him.
Wait.
every time i'm like can i though can i actually kill him i
thought oh okay my range his armies before the combat oh
okay you be closer you stand over here we start now walk
okay that's fine closer now with my luck with my lucky shoes
all right there we go see i told you guys it's possible now
what is over here my wood now those cowards oh i get more
movement points those cowards i'm coming over i'm gonna kill
your teammates you can't hide forever I'm coming over to get
you.
Alright.
That's right.
Can't hide forever from me.
I'm walking over very slowly.
But I'm getting there.
Can't protect you forever.
By the gods.
That's right.
I'm taking her sand, too.
I'm almost there.
I'm almost here.
I know my objective is to get all the mines, but what if I
also...
Oh my god, I got the hydra.
I know my objectives was to get the mines, but also what if
I kill you instead?
I don't need to get any of that That's right I'm almost
there I'm almost there Just you wait Just you Oh wait a
movement That's right Sorsha Time to go
Alright we're gonna go This way Then he'll slowly crawl over
so will he and then so will he and then boom that's right oh
shit forgot about my magic don't worry i also have my magic
uh the spell removes all spell effects um uh magic i too
have magic i'm gonna get your archer i'm almost there Oh my
god, you're so dead.
That's right.
The cow's here now.
Oh my god.
And another one.
Get out of here.
Basic archery.
Okay, we need that.
That's right.
You saw what I did there?
You're next.
The cows are here now.
You're fucking next.
I got my eyes on you.
That's right.
Hell yeah.
Oh my god, I have an idea.
I know what to do.
Alright, how much money do I have?
Oh?
Oh, it's not upgraded yet.
Oh, Mega Gorgon.
Yeah, get over here.
Alright, I have an idea.
All right, we're going to get, we're going to fuel up.
Oh my god, they resder.
They fucking resder.
You think that's going to stop me?
Okay, let's see.
You know, I'm just going to take your other house.
Fuck this.
Don't worry.
I have a refuel point.
I'm going to refuel.
You think that's gonna stop me?
Watch this.
Don't worry.
I'm refueling.
I'm refueling my people.
Oh my god, I could have got two more hydras in here.
Oh shit, whatever.
That's fine.
Watch this.
I'm going to go doing a pit stop real quick.
That's right.
Refuel!
Uh, send them all in!
Wait, can I...
Oh, I can upgrade that.
Alright, we're gonna get rid of that.
And then get...
What do I get rid of?
And then get the Hydra in here.
Fuck it.
Alright, refuel.
Alright, go back home.
It's over.
It's so over for you.
I refueled.
It really is so over for this man.
Oh, shit.
A Thrawn?
How much is a Thrawn?
All right.
Do you think I have enough, actually?
A singular set.
Wait, do I even have enough for this guy?
Fuck this.
I'm going to kill your guy.
I'm going to kill this guy and take your house.
Is there enough magic?
Guys, do I have enough against him?
I can't tell.
Only one way to find out.
Oh.
I don't know.
Is it worth it?
Might be close.
It might be, actually.
as much refuel as i thought
the grip i'm a i am a little bit afraid of the griffins guys
i am a little bit afraid because it's like all or nothing
and the same and storm yeah i'm afraid i'm actually afraid
of the you know i'll just take the town around him i'll
refuel later
maybe i'll take the town next door Oh, I don't know.
I don't know if it's worth it.
We're challenging him.
Now that I saw how much he has.
I can't tell if it's worth challenging him.
Do it?
Be a brave bird.
It's not fair.
He's huddled up in his house.
That fucking coward.
He's in his house.
It's not coming out like a little bitch.
How am I supposed to kill him if he won't come out?
Okay.
It's called a siege dokey.
It's not fair.
Yeah, I'll accept.
Come over here.
Oh, my God.
All right.
We're going to do it.
If we die, we die.
Oh, we might die.
we oh don't do it we go in fly oh shit oh shit okay don't
worry we'll kill him
all right oh cow might be dead though cow might be fucked a
little Okay.
Don't worry, we're slowly walking over.
We're slowly walking over.
My Hydra's here.
My one Hydra.
I'm going to kill the Archer's first, actually.
The Archer is what scares me the most.
I'm gonna fly all the way here to kill this one guy.
Fuck that one guy.
That's not fair.
I can magic, too.
Magic!
Kill him!
Oh, no.
All right.
Work on him.
We gotta slowly work our way over to that guy.
All right.
Slowly walk over.
And then Hydra him.
And then...
All right, that's a lot of Gryffins dead.
All right, there you go.
I actually was the most scared of was that guy.
Okay.
So shoot him.
Don't worry, I also have magic.
I don't have magic.
No, my Hydra!
All right.
Okay.
We'll just slowly mow down the archers.
archers.
And then him.
Okay.
Beat him up!
Oh shit, he's still alive?
Beat him up again!
Alright, there we go.
Archer versus archer!
There we go.
It's worth it!
Oh my god, he has more tactical experience than me.
Okay, get in there, cow!
It's time!
Fight him!
Fight his ass!
Oh, shit.
He bit my ass.
It's okay.
I'm breaching the perimeters.
The archer versus archer fight.
Alright, there.
He should be dead soon.
I win.
Yay!
Alright, advance archery.
Basic.
No, advance.
Ooh.
Basic artillery.
That's right.
It's my house now.
It's my house now, bitch.
That's right.
And I know you have nothing.
Get over here.
I know you have nothing.
All my men might be dead.
But yours is dead dead.
Oh, I only have two spell points left.
Well, we'll let the recharge, I guess.
I'm yam-yam.
I sure showed him.
There we go.
Get over here.
I'm not done with you.
I'm not done.
I'm ready for round two.
Let's see.
Let's upgrade.
Just for fun.
Let's upgrade him.
All right, how much money do I have?
7,000?
A reinforcements tab.
If he takes my house, I swear to God.
Oh, I can recruit stuff now.
Yay.
Uh.
Grab that.
That's right.
I live here.
Oh, you're going home?
You're going home?
Oh, you scared?
Get over here.
Get expert artillery.
And then we'll grab that too.
Oh, he's scared.
He's so fucking scared.
That's right.
What?
What's that gonna stop me?
Yeah, that's fucking right.
I'm coming over.
Oh, one guy.
All right, let's...
Okay.
Let's...
all right nice all right uh increases your heroes movement
over land grab that all right how is it still attackable
what are you gonna do without that nothing what are you
gonna do that's looking right and nothing oh shit wait he
hexed me oh no i got hexed i'm coming over boom oh wait it's
the Oh my god, he's gonna chop me.
Unless I chop him back.
That's right, I'm slowly crawling over.
That's right.
Red has been vanquished.
The land is mine now.
Don't keep it.
That's right.
Now I can just casually explore.
I need to get all the mines.
Where are the mines?
Oh, there it is.
I didn't.
It's just the ore pits, right?
It's all coming up for Doki.
That's fucking right.
I'm not enough money.
Oh, I'm broke.
It's okay.
I'll just raise taxes.
All right.
Taxes are going to be raised soon.
Oh, join your army for 29 gold?
Oh, 29.
Yeah, fuck it.
Join my army.
I don't care.
I've already killed everybody.
It's now just to chill.
Is it the orpid?
It's just the mines or is there everything else?
That's right.
As your new leader.
I say more taxes.
More taxes.
Every mine's a gem.
Oh my god.
all of them all right guys it's just all right we can you
can i guess you can leave now i gotta get the army up so
then these guys can actually explore all
right let's see
how many men do i have in here 154 i can kill these guys no
all right where am i missing don't worry taxes will now be
up by 50 if you're not part of faction if you are a human
your taxes will be increased by 50% if you are not a human
your taxes are increased by 30% see I'm fair I'm fair to all
kind historically accurate I see get out of here give me my
money okay basic tactics no this guy I just want money.
Wait, does my characters like, cross over?
Yeah, you want to join my army.
Fuck it.
We'll let the...
Like, do they...
If I play with these... Do I...
Do they cross over to other campaigns or now?
Or to the next campaign?
I don't remember.
Is it worth leveling...
They do?
Alright, we'll upgrade them.
If they do, I'll just upgrade them.
Let's see no armies don't okay because I was thinking about
the experience and stuff if I should keep the experience or
anything because if they cross over then I'll just I can
just keep all right I think I think they're strong enough
maybe I'm a little worried about because I need to get all
the minds but there's only I only have one guy that's like
strong Oh, wait.
Oh, we'll kill this, Griffin.
Oh, that is unfortunate.
Oh,
that should be fine.
Right?
That is more than one Doki.
Oh, yeah, that should be fine.
It should be fine.
Yeah, see, I knew my lizard men got this.
If anything, my lizard men.
There we go.
That's right.
Smack them with your fucking mace.
I knew my lizard men got this.
I told you.
if anybody's got this it's my lizard people if anybody's
there for me
oh okay wait all right now she can go out be free do i have
everything what do i not have is that the last one that
actually might be my last one whoa whoa oh dad needs his
walkies all right guys listen i'll be right back just giving
dad his walkies oh god all right i'll be right back giving
dad you really wants walkies now all right let me get the
text giving dad walkies right now all right don't worry i'll
let you i'll let you listen to music all right i'll be right
back I am back.
He barked at a child.
Dad, dad barked at a child.
It was not great.
It's just like, we're looking at it.
There was like a little child too.
And I had to like be like, I'm so sorry.
I am so sorry.
He really does not like children.
But I am back now.
It's time to do my favorite thing.
Taxation.
Alright.
Did I get everything?
I think it's literally just that one mine.
I think.
It has to be.
There's nothing else here.
It's literally just that one mine.
Let's kill him and grab it.
Why do they all want to fight me?
Oh my god.
Not here.
I want him to be over here, please.
And then you can be here.
Alright, let's start.
Alright.
Uh, you killed the closest guy to you.
Alright, there we go.
And then...
Oh, I don't have enough magic.
It's fine.
I'm slowly walking over.
Boom.
Don't worry.
The crew is here.
No taxation without representation.
I don't can't gain any more experience.
Why not?
All right, I did it.
There's more mines.
Where are the rest of the mines?
Okay.
I got that.
Where are they hiding?
Okay, it must be up here.
The towers don't count.
There's no wood in there.
What am I missing?
Okay.
They fear the Doki Taks.
I actually don't even know what I'm missing.
But what if I want to be OP?
You can't stop me?
Oh my god.
Is it in the portal?
It's in the portal, isn't it?
Give me your men.
They're part of my army now.
Alright, let's upgrade these guys.
Get him in here.
They're part of my crew now.
Get out of here.
Alright.
like I.
I'm gonna kill that lizard, man.
I don't fuck with the cows.
I don't fuck with the cows anymore.
Alright, let's grab a stable, too.
Or the movement.
I'm too scared about the cows.
Alright, let's grab this.
Yes, I wish the pass.
Get me into that portal.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's here!
Let me fight you.
Alright, there's 15 of you.
I can take you.
Alright, we'll hide behind here.
And then here.
Start combat.
Get over here.
That's alright.
It's the final one.
Grab the one with a 16.
Yeah.
Fight him Alright, the lizard is coming There we go Alright,
yoink Yay!
I did it!
Taxes for all Yay!
In times of strife, your merchant ways will earn you great
rewards So these are my favorite factions.
Is this one?
It's this.
I want the eagle.
Wait, but then...
Wait, isn't...
Oh, wait, but then I can get the ancient behemoth.
Oh, they're all good.
I don't know if I want the...
Okay, I must have 200,000 gold?
That's a lot.
Wait, but then ancient behemoth, though.
Guys, look, I did it without cheating.
Look, guys.
I did it now.
It's ta-
200k!
I gotta tax more!
I gotta pretend for some land grab is presenting stuff in
the- I'm gonna get the birds.
Just cause there's more birds.
There's only one behemoth, but I can have more birds.
Your abilities have been brought to the attention of the
barbarian nation of Kulod.
Their skirmishes with the Arafian military on their eastern
border are legendary.
Many credit them for hardening Arafian soldiers.
Recently a border raid resulted in more fulfilling right
now.
I want to I need eagles.
I need more archangels guys What if what if what if what if
it'd be so funny?
What if I what if you know, what if I just do one round
guys?
Haha, what if?
Once they have the resources they need.
It's just what if Until then your independent participation
is needed.
It would be so funny though overzealous clan leader acting
outside what if what if yeah i'd be one level legit i should
be able to it's like one one legit one not legit one legit
one lot not legit see even no you're already eight you're
already eight you're already eight you're already eight you
already eight you already eight you already eight you
already eight just one for nostalgia's sake you know you
know just a little
I'm done.
He just wanted water.
He just wanted water, but now that I'm here, he's like, you
might as well give me some poo too.
And I'm like, oh, fuck, okay.
Law on how we skirmish with the Ethereum military on an
eastern border.
Many credit us for hardening your soldiers into the strong
fighters that have become.
A recent border raid resulted in victory, but also resulted
in characteristic large number of prisoners.
Also, uh...
say if all the sound the sound is okay now I couldn't tell
all right yeah all right our interrogations of these
prisoners confirmed our suspicion without their king
Eurythia has no heart our goal is not to start a war but to
quickly plunder the land that is easily within our reach
once we have resources that we need war can be discussed
until then we require independent participation to raid the
Erythraean territories to our immediate east.
Should you be captured?
We will claim you were merely an oversellless clan and
you're acting outside in the interest of nation.
You'll be paid well, but we need to work for your money.
The Duke has determined that Kruelor will need at least
200,000 gold to fund any further ventures.
How?
That's too many gold.
How am I gonna find 200k?
Oh my god, that's way too many good taxes, dokey.
That's out.
That's the only way.
I have to get the town hall right off the bat.
Okay, let's get the watering hole.
That's so many!
Yeah, base allows you to negotiate to weaker and reduce the
cost of surrendering but yeah let's get that and we can have
one a day you know how don't play dumb with me dokey how
will i ever get 200k okay let's grab uh for a thousand gold
Okay, get spell power.
Let's grab spell power.
How would I do such a thing?
Okay, this guy has the most stuff.
So we're gonna have to farm stuff real quick.
We need Mage Guild, level one, marketplace.
Okay.
Don't worry, I'm doing the long game right now.
and then they have enough money to like recruit people
grab this oh i should have got mad i should have got money i
just needed money
i already forgot the task
okay beat him all right
all right so this is also one of my favorite factions too i
liked uh this one the the swamp one and then the the harpy
lady squad those were the three that i liked i didn't fuck
with the others uh marketplace don't worry i might be spent
i'm spending money to make money guys Guys, trust the
process.
You gotta spend money to make money.
Trust the process, everyone.
Inflected.
Increases all hand to hand.
Okay, I like that.
It's an investment.
I'm investing.
Okay, and then we can grab that.
And then we just need blacksmith.
I keep forgetting to swap.
from here.
There we go.
No, we're not broke yet.
We set up 20k.
And we have sand.
And we have rock.
And we have that.
And then I'm going to recruit all of these guys.
Would you like?
Yes, please.
Give me all of them.
And now now look at this.
Bam!
City hall.
Oh, oh, and then bam!
Another 2k.
Look at that.
right off the bat.
I'll grab this and then we'll just keep recruiting.
That's fine.
We gotta spend money to make money.
And now, CASA and uh...
$5,000?
Did I not have $5,000?
What do I not have?
Raw?
Wait, I should have it.
Can I make another...
Why can't I make another...
Can I make another castle?
Oh, I don't have it here.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Our treasury is lacking right now.
What else do we need?
Okay.
Okay, that is a little...
A little oopsie.
We might have ran out of wood here.
But that is okay.
Because I can build...
Bam!
A resource silo.
Alright, and then we grab...
Rock.
Okay, it might look like I'm broke right now, but, but, I
shall save my money.
I shall save my money.
It looks like I'm broke, but it's not.
Did I have this already?
I did.
That, did I do all of these?
Okay.
It only looks like I'm broke.
5,000.
Alright, we'll wait.
We'll grab gold just in case.
Basic luck.
Expert R.
Offense.
Okay, this will be my fighter.
And grab armor.
And then we'll grab this.
And we'll grab more money here.
And then, now!
Wait, actually...
yes oh wait okay it doesn't matter okay now i build my army
guys this is where the army is formed i'll build my army
here on the other one i feel i should give it okay nine
twelve thousand okay gold is the same so i'll build my army
here we'll get the wolves and this one can chill
We'll give you wood Just in case Alright It's fine See
everything is fine Guys trust the process
This is my fighter
The basic tactics Basic offense And then Advanced artillery
She will fight for me I feel like Wait This would be where I
Recruit my army
Alright I have nothing So I'm just gonna We'll grab you here
Oh This one is always good Alright you're just gonna Your
duty After I I'm done here After I grab all of this She
fights Guys Don't worry.
She will fight.
It's a process.
Oh my god, I can get the Behemoth Lair right now.
Okay.
And your job is to exist.
Uh, you don't need anything.
This place, this is just my... Wait.
Yeah, this is my earning... This is my money maker.
And then this one is my people maker.
I don't think I need to actually need anything.
Do I?
I feel like None of these matter.
Increases that attack skill.
Oh, maybe I need the Hala Valhalla.
Just in case.
Your job is to just exist.
Your job is to get me money.
Oh, I can make a ship.
Okay, we're gonna go...
Oh, we're gonna go home.
Go home.
Grab people.
Alright.
And then...
You know what?
Grab one more guy for the road, too.
all right and then off we go we fight kill him kill this one
guy fuck that guy all right do i need anything else no i'm
good all right and then i guess i can build a boat he lives
there all right this boat is for the other the other woman
All right, get him!
Okay, let's see.
We need, like, who's the archers?
This is the, oh, it's the Cyclops.
Right?
The Cyclops are the archers.
Okay, I need Arc Tower.
All right, you pick this up.
And grab this too.
You, kill him!
Still kill him!
Oh, wait, this is a crit.
Actually, no.
kill them first okay an orc for it I need trees 3,000 I'll
upgrade this then for now okay we're just gonna grab some
stuff kill this man that's right run that's right rob it
their graves too oh nice i'm just gonna zap him there you go
i don't want to deal with these guys all right come over
behemoth what are you gonna do suck his blood it's poison
i want to just kill them first and then kill the witch
Oh my god, we're so far.
Fuck it.
I know it's like one.
He's just one guy.
But I'm sending a message right now.
Ooh.
I like that.
Okay, I still need 20.
But I could spend it on an upgrade.
All right, we have this.
Have we done the witch hunt yet?
I don't remember.
Whatever.
We'll grab this real quick, and then we'll grab the
telescope, too.
Now we kill him for real.
I know I keep saying we're going to get him, but this time
I'm going to get him.
I don't need another hero.
I got all I need right here in my little town.
I have all I need in my little town.
Ooh, maybe I could actually, let's give him here.
Let's put him here.
Oh, my God.
There you are.
I see you.
And I got everything.
Arena.
Let's grab the arena.
Okay.
Run.
That's right.
I know you're gonna run.
It's mine now.
Alright.
Uh.
Thing is, I don't want to invest here.
I want to invest in this town.
So I can have my army here.
I just need 200k.
all i need and
there's no room who has not been upgraded oh you
um grab the wood oh who's not been upgraded oh wait same
people all right
whoa you know what we'll grab more magic too yeah we'll grab
people here and then we'll Upgrade you.
Alright.
My army now.
And then now we have two armies.
And we're sent.
Yay.
And I know Bracic for save.
Uh.
Okay.
Now we can upgrade that too.
And then.
Creatures for resources.
I don't think I really need that honestly.
Why would you chill?
Oh, I already did that.
I was just like, I'll do it again.
Attack.
Attack is the best defense.
Alright.
Do I need a...
You know what?
Fuck it.
I have two strong characters.
I'm going on the boat.
Yeah.
We'll keep upgrading these guys.
This is my people town.
The other one will be my hangout town.
See you.
Yeah, this one will just be the hangout.
Hangout with the crew.
No leave.
Alright.
I'm gonna go on the boat now.
This guy can use it to hang out with all the fun people.
Arneen.
What do you need?
What?
I just need wood.
I need more mills.
I realize.
Wait, did I visit this already?
Yeah, I did.
Alright, I need gold.
Join my army!
Yes!
Diplomacy.
So I don't have to fuck with these people.
Alright.
Get out of here.
More magic.
Oh, fuck, I was supposed to.
God damn it.
Oh, upgrade.
Yes!
I have so much money now!
Recruit them all!
I know I should be saving money.
I have so much money!
Let me spend it all, everyone!
I have so much money now!
Which means I can spend it all!
What was my task again?
I don't remember.
I'm going to keep spending.
She did it.
I'm like, oh yeah, what was my original objective again?
Doesn't matter.
Let me spend my money.
That, good luck.
Wait, what?
Someone lives here.
Do I have enough?
I'm just gonna kill them So I'm coming over Yes, the
upgrades
Are they all upgraded?
Yeah, they are And now I can now I can slowly grab people
Someone lives here someone you to live here.
Oh shit.
This could have been a bad idea.
Alright, we'll start.
I just realized I don't really have anybody that can kill
the archer.
I just realized that.
We'll go...
We're gonna go straight for the archer.
I don't care.
Like, we gotta get rid of him.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
No, my behemoth!
My bird!
Okay.
Who's that lucky throw?
Alright, I killed the archer.
That one is the most important.
Oh, my god!
My behemoth!
Oh shit!
I want to try killing the Griffin first.
Not my behemoth!
Don't worry, he's slowly walking over.
I still want to kill the archer.
It's okay, it's still winnable.
We lost the bird, but we got plenty more birds.
There we go, see?
I told you- oh fuck, I forgot about that guy.
I literally forgot this guy existed.
Oh shit, not the double attack.
Okay, I still have my birds.
Okay, if I kill him first.
Alright, let's all gang up on this guy.
Okay, we all gang up on him.
There we go.
See, that's all it takes.
Oh shit, that's just kids okay.
Oh, maybe.
And another one?
Focus fire.
Lucky!
Oh, wait, nice, nice.
There we go.
Oh, we lost a lot.
Okay.
It's okay.
We got it.
We got a town.
I didn't even know there was a town here.
You know what that means?
More taxes.
Uh, learn.
Reduce fire.
All right.
basic advanced tactics i'll grab that you know what that
means guys we need more taxes yay that's what i like to see
okay we'll grab our tower here and then we'll grab all about
tax them all exactly i like the way you think
you want to grab the stables i need to increase my movement
all right the seed will help you speed in your travels alas
this is your inspo weighing with a lot of heavy riding must
return for a fresh mount i need to return for a fresh mount
that's bullshit
i have them okay i I do have it.
Alright, we'll grab this real quick.
I'll grab the extra money.
And then this.
And then I need to refuel soon.
Okay, we got the gold.
Alright, that's a hoard.
Alright, what do I have?
I'll fight this lady first.
Oh yeah, no, he's dead.
Oh yeah, no, goodbye.
There we go.
uh goodbye i don't know about you though that's what i'm i
don't know yeah i gotta take the horse the horse repair shop
like what kind of bullshit is that my horse needs to be
repaired
is it new week yet
all right uh i don't know what to do with this city so i'm
just gonna Loot.
I don't know what to do with you.
I'm just going to loot.
Oh, I got a cape of conjuring.
I got a sword.
I'm going to take your wood first before I decide to fight
you.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's worth it.
I don't really have...
I have a lot of people, but it doesn't mean I have a lot
of...
It doesn't mean...
I have a lot of different types of people, but not a lot of
them.
So that's what I'm most worried about.
Fuck it.
Do I have another...
I'm gonna bring her back.
I'll be back.
I'm just gonna take your surrounding area, but I'll be back.
Or... Yeah, I'll be back.
Or... I have an idea.
Where's my recruitment?
Okay.
We're gonna travel over.
Do I know magic?
Do I?
Okay, yeah, I do.
Okay, now I do.
Alright, I'm coming over.
We're doing a pit stop.
We're gonna do a little pit stop real quick.
I don't think I can kill them.
They have a horde of them.
I don't really have a horde of anything.
I'll be back!
Yeah, I'm doing a little pit stop right here.
Do I build another boat?
How much is a boat?
Okay, it's a thousand.
Alright, I'm coming over.
We're gonna...
We're gonna swap places.
You know what?
I have the money.
Fuck it.
And then...
More magic.
I'm you're just here to get taxed honestly like your your
existence is to be taxed
oh shit wrong one oh my god how much money to accidentally
spend I was trying to do this area I was like a hundred when
did I have a hundred people there whoops oh that there goes
all my money oh there goes all my money Oh, that's a
little...
Oh, that's a little awkward.
Alright.
I think...
Oh, fuck.
I was supposed to...
Okay, yeah.
I was like, wait a minute.
It was not that expensive last time.
That doesn't make sense.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
That's a lot of my money.
That money was That money was supposed to go in my pocket
You're gonna wonder what happened to the 200k And I'll be
like same Okay
Wait which is which Who's this guy?
Okay here Alright Oh they're all upgraded I'll get your bird
And then I'll get these guys and I'll grab these guys and
and I guess you go
all right we kill him now we kill we kill you I think we
have we have the people now and you go refuel and then
she'll go refuel yeah I know that's I was like debating
where I should what i should do i was like what do i do
it's time
okay i think i have everything here i have to go to i'm
gonna grab all the stuff here that i'm missing all right we
refuel again all right okay we can do this
Oh no!
Oh no.
Okay, we're gonna get rid of the archer.
I hope.
Oh no.
That is a lot of Pikmin.
That really is a lot.
Oh no.
Oh, fuck.
Really?
Another one?
I'm gonna just start throwing shit at him.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, my God.
He's so fast.
Hit.
Why?
What did the dog do to you?
That's it.
Bird time.
Oh, my God.
He's so fast.
holy shit there's not any of them magic question mark let's
see if we can slowly kill him oh shit alright let's see if
we can slowly kill him
oh I forgot about that guy I actually forgot about him oh
please don't kill my bird
okay I'm gonna use my magic stick okay Okay, bird, you, you
mow this guy down.
I think that's our only hope right now.
That's just one guy, so that's five.
And then whose turn is it?
Oh, who, oh, is this guy?
All right.
You just smack him.
And then it should be fine.
Uh, there we go.
All right, the bird might die, but that's okay.
That's the sacrifice I'm willing to take.
all right bird your sacrifice won't be in vain don't worry
the ancient behemoth is here we'll start smacking them down
one by one okay
don't worry ogre mom is here okay there you go see
everything is fine nothing to worry about where is he going
what the fuck he just wants to smack the girl oh my god it's
okay see Nothing to worry about.
We did it.
Nothing to worry about.
Basic armor.
Look at my house now.
Look at that, guys.
See, I told you.
More taxes.
I told you there was nothing to worry about.
Everything was fine.
See, look at that.
Oh my god, no.
Wait, wait a minute.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's coming back for revenge.
I'm coming.
I'm going.
My house.
He's coming back for revenge.
We refuel.
There's more.
What?
okay it's okay if he loses i refueled i still have three
turns to get over there save him and then come back okay i
refuel here too
okay all right i should be able to upgrade his house too
okay i cannot okay i cannot upgrade his house okay that is
okay uh uh What can I do?
What do you mean?
Okay, I can.
I'm gonna make griffins.
All right, those are mine now.
You're my griffins now.
Surely it won't come invade.
Oh, he's coming back.
Surely it won't come back, right?
He's coming back, guys.
He's coming back.
I don't have a ballistic.
What can I...
I get stronger magic?
I get...
Oh my god, he took them off!
Uh...
I think the strat is the seven angels.
Where's the... wait, where's the...
Okay.
I am a visiting!
Oh, okay.
There you are, I purchased the ballistic, but it's not
really much.
Okay, if I buy archers, I can grab archers too.
But then, but then he'll be able to grab archers too later.
Oh my god, he's coming over.
You want to...
He's like, he's coming over, guys.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh my god, he wants to fight.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna stay here.
He's coming.
Okay.
They'll have to come to me, though.
If I stay in here, they can't do anything about it.
Because he has to come to me.
Alright, I'm staying here.
And I'm going to slowly kill their archer.
I'm just going to stay here.
That's right.
You got to come to me.
Oh my god, he's coming over to me.
He's...
Wait a minute.
He is coming over to me.
Oh, wait a minute.
Don't worry, I'll defend you, Cyclops.
I didn't expect that.
Oh my god, they blinded him.
What am I moving?
Okay.
Don't worry, I'm going to protect him.
Oh my god, he gets another movement!
Alright.
You...
stay here and then you get the range
oh this is so bad i hope this is oh no okay who's next
all right i give you a power up you get another attack you
bitch it's all right we can slowly keep our oh fuck it is
getting a little scary
oh god it's okay we're gonna have to smack him all right we
got him okay we got him oh my god he's got me oh fuck okay
How many?
There's 21 and 7.
I'll take my odds.
Oh my god.
My behemoth is trying so hard right now.
He's like my only DPS right now.
He really is.
Oh my god, DPS down.
DPS down.
Okay, all right, there we go, Steve.
Oh my god, we lived.
We lived.
Okay, we lived.
DPS lives.
All right, that was a little scary, guys.
Oh, that was a little too scary.
Just a little bit too scary, guys.
and the upgrade orc tower only a little bit okay we'll grab
these guys we gotta recruit uh you know what you get the you
know what you get the pikeman actually no i should get more
Yeah, I need more range.
Alright.
I've restocked.
I'm going in.
Alright, we're gonna go refuel our fellow men.
We're gonna refuel real quick.
That was very scary.
That was a little too close.
Just a little too close for comfort.
All right.
I'm going to refuel here.
And then...
You go talk to her.
All right, you stop here.
So that I can explore more later.
Yeah, that guy saved the day.
He really did.
He actually came in fucking clutch.
I'm going to go recruit some right now.
All right.
uh slowly upgrade more here i don't care about this guy
these guys to be fair
all right okay go go refuel all right uh jesus christ
all right we have refueled we do need a let's see all right
you get to keep the one arch here all right now we go you
know what now we go home okay now we get back our gold and
then we go explore up
uh i feel like i don't need anything honestly i'll just
upgrade castle just for fun i'm just slowly upgrading my
people here
Wait, did I do this part yet?
No.
Alright, more movement is always good.
Now where do I live?
Where do I live right now?
Alright, we go.
You know what?
I'll scout.
Wait, there was like nothing here.
We found Cyclops.
Yeah, attack them!
Oh, shit!
Everything will be fine.
Okay.
Don't attack here?
Oh, shit.
They don't insta-kill.
Wait, that's bad.
Okay, we got maybe stock up.
We might need a...
We actually might need a, like...
There we go.
I realize they don't kill them all at the same time.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, that's not good.
Wait a minute.
That's not good.
Alright.
Oh, don't tell me.
me, I gotta restock again.
Yo.
Val does.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
We just lost 25 men.
That's okay.
It's just a, just, just a little, oopsie.
Just a little bit.
Don't worry.
Everything, I know I keep saying everything will be fine,
but everything will be fine.
Do not worry.
Everyone stay calm.
Why are people stay calm, everybody.
Stay calm.
I have Pikeman Griff.
Wait, do I have everything?
Oh, yeah, I do.
I'll grab the Griffman Bastion just in case.
We're so healthy.
We are so healthy.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I can take him.
I can take him.
Wait, how come he gets to have that?
Do not worry.
I restocked.
Okay.
Ooh.
I'm going to go straight for the archer, as always.
Just run straight at him.
Griffin versus Griffin.
See.
Oh, cool.
Ice ball.
Forgetfulness.
Oh.
Wait, that's right.
No range attack for you.
Oh, so that means I can kill him.
Well, he can kill me, but I can kill him.
Oh, shit.
Oh, oh, that's not good.
I'm just going to slowly walk up with my behemoth.
Oh, my God.
What?
Oh, that is not good.
Oh.
Oh my god, but even if he just collapsed, what happened to
him?
He's just, he's collapsed.
What?
Okay, we got to use magic here.
Okay, let's let's let's try and do something.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God, my poor man.
Oh, my God.
What happened to him?
But I thought I could take him.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
There's still hope.
I freeze him.
Okay.
Oh, my poor bird.
My poor, poor, poor bird.
Okay, he's dead.
That's good.
Okay, there you go.
I told you guys.
I told you.
I can take him.
I told... It's fine.
It's fine.
It came from up here.
Surely there's nothing bad up here.
Alright.
I told you we can take him.
Oh my god.
It's back here.
We're back here?
See you guys?
Not even close.
Maybe I should...
I'll refuel.
her and then go back oh my god that's the perfect plan wait
who's her okay i'll refuel you and then everything will be
fine okay we're gonna trade that for that and then that for
that there we go now you're refueled and you can keep on
progressing you go home you go home oh my god oh please
i'm just a little baby
oh no not again here we go again turkey here we go oh that's
not that's not good that is not good at all that is not good
at all oh that's awkward that's very awkward um what am i
gonna do with them uh oh i could guarantee a turn to
surrender you're so right that is so smart i should do that
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
What?
There we go.
They'll never know.
Look at that.
I should have at least one turn.
I...
I might be able to run away.
You're so right.
Surely.
How could they know?
They'll be like, oh my god, there's so many people over
there.
Little dude, they...
They took my boat!
What the...
She took my boat!
What the fuck?
There's no way there's one of you.
Oh my god, and then he sent out lightning.
Okay.
My boat!
You wake up my boat now.
He took my boat
impossible.
Oh, yeah.
It's time to save her.
The boat.
Yeah, I know.
What do I do?
What can I even do?
She has my boat.
What can I do?
I'm stuck here.
What?
3d chess move she knew they knew they knew I was gonna die
with my I didn't even realize you can die if they take your
boat the boat is just gone oh my god he just came back to
york his shit back that's fucked that is so fucked that is
absolute oh my god okay how many houses you have how many
fucking houses Okay.
I gotta buy another boat.
And I have to refuel.
Oh my god, I could take it back.
Fuck you.
Oh, he has a lot of people.
I'm just gonna...
Who is he?
Who is this person?
All right.
Don't worry.
I'm coming over.
Okay.
I might be able to kill him, though.
He just has one guy.
I can kill him.
I know I can kill this guy.
All right, we got restocked.
All right.
Okay, we're going to grab some more people.
there's no room oh wait yeah we're restock and refuel our
men it's all about refueling
all right and then i don't i'm lost i'm there's so many
teleporters now there's so many teleporters i don't know
which teleporter goes to which anymore there's way too many
and then we'll refuel
idea we refuel we buy a guy get over here refueled some more
and then oh my god he's coming over it oh my god like this
never ends this doesn't end oh my god like when will this
end like oh my god and he got more men this is not fair oh
i'm stuck here okay i'm gonna refuel with you and now grab
here he comes over lands here yes we got by as many people
as possible oh my god forgot these guys are babies I forgot
I can't even refuel these you gotta upgrade them oh my okay
alright we got this we go here I connect with her guys just
fair way with me.
This is a... This planet is perfect.
We wait.
And then... I go down here.
He comes over here.
I refill each other.
I run away.
Not like a coward, but I'm leaving.
And I go here and then i go here and then i also go here
they're all coming don't worry trust the process and then i
go here he talks to her and i bring in the reinforcements
all right there we go that should be enough that should be
plenty enough people to kill someone like that right wait
how am i how do i have no more space who's still okay it's
the griffin all right there we go now i can kill you now i'm
gonna trust the process okay all right you leave you go home
okay you stand over here so she can go over here and then i
have several here I have several people to refuel you go
home and then I fight there we go there we go and then okay
I don't need to waste it I I just kill you all right there
we go there we go and then I take you this guy's house so I
can tax people there's no way there can be that many people.
There we go.
I- Okay, there we go.
There you go.
See, I told you.
Trust the process.
There you go.
There's no way.
All right.
There we go.
We just have to trust the process.
We're gonna- Oh, I don't have enough.
Okay.
I'm just gonna- I'm just gonna- You know what?
Fuck you in particular.
Here we go.
Oh shit.
Okay, that's fine We just have to kill this guy that guy
fuck that guy in particular Who's who's who's it whose move
is it whose turn is it wolf guy?
Okay wolf guy All right, and then I'll slowly walk over
where did I hit?
all right we haven't breached the defenses yet that's good
they're coming to me that's actually really good all right
get that bloodlust in there and then get that arrow in out
there too all right chop we did it we fucking did it i told
you power of refuel oh my god that guy is so strong
I'll just take the rock and then this and hope this guy
won't attack me that's the whole plan if this guy doesn't
attack me my plan is solid that's like my entire hope as
long as that guy doesn't attack me all right oh all right as
a new friend I I can wait here it's fine i'll wait here
until refuel number two is ready you know what what the fuck
okay we'll kill him all right can i meet up with him oh i'm
scared i'm just gonna i'm scared if i go through like the
other guy's gonna try intervene that's what i'm worried
about is there a plan b i'm this is all in this is plan b
i'm going all in here let's hope let's hope oh oh oh no oh
nope he wants his home back okay all right this is a little
awkward now okay we gotta go home live here.
I don't get.
He wants his home back.
I did not anticipate that he would try and get his house
back.
Isn't that crazy?
He wants his house back.
Who would have thought?
Who would have thought he would want to live?
He would want his house back.
But if he does get his house back, I can kill him.
I have refuel number two coming in hot.
And refuel number three is awesome.
coming over here too.
oh, I still need to bring it down.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
I didn't even realize I was still too loud throughout that
stream.
No!
Alright.
We'll go back.
He just wants a house.
Alright, and then my one arrow team.
Okay.
Surely.
He's too scared.
That's good.
He's scared.
He doesn't know that I am also a little scared.
He doesn't know that, which is also good.
He doesn't know.
Alright, this is it.
This is it.
Okay.
Get out.
We refuel again.
Which one?
Okay, here you go.
Alright.
He's also scared.
He doesn't know.
I thank God.
He doesn't know that I am also scared.
Alright.
And then we kill him!
Is that the main guy?
Okay.
And then we kill him!
There we go.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
It all went according to plan.
We're gonna go kill him now.
Nothing to worry about.
See?
It all works out.
Don't worry.
I can give him bloodlust.
I'll put him here.
All right.
What do I kill first?
I feel like I have to kill him first, right?
But what if I kill him first?
Okay, but I can also...
We're gonna make him free at first.
We gotta make him not do anything.
And then...
And then we'll kill him!
Or I'll kill him first.
No, I'll kill him first.
I'll kill you!
There we go.
All right.
And then we'll slowly...
There we go.
We don't need a slow leak.
And then I'll slowly make sure...
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Everything's fine.
See, everything's fine.
I told you.
We don't need to do this slowly.
And we just...
We just go all in.
That's the best part.
Magic!
Yeah, I think we can...
There we go.
Okay, we did it.
We just lost four or two wolves.
There we go.
See?
to worry about all right now we take our house all right and
then the third refuel is here too oh my god where did this
guy come from okay it's fine all right okay where's the all
right you can live here i don't care what you're gonna do
you just chill here at least there's people in the house all
right all right and then the second pit stop Now for the
real fight.
The second pit stop is here.
Alright, here we go.
Pit stop number three.
This is not overkill.
I need as many men as possible.
There we go.
This is the strategy.
We got another pit stop.
Alright.
I believe.
Alright, this is your time to shine.
There we go.
I don't even need moves.
He knows what's up.
I need 200k gold I don't even need a move.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's just start combat.
I'm just gonna zap.
Zap!
Oh wait, he's live.
He's alive.
You know what?
Retreat.
Wait.
Chuck.
There we go.
All right.
Let's invade.
Yeah, I know this is, yeah, I know this is, you know what?
Let's see how the AI does it.
Wait, why did my guy walk up?
There we go.
Let the AI handle this.
you know what I don't even need a try I'm not even gonna let
you have the satisfaction there we go nice yay all right
it's just farming it's just taxation time all right now I
just grab these yep I'm sure literally nothing else I could
do it's just tax time I just gotta wait for taxes just win
with taxes now what am i supposed to do
yeah taxed everyone yippee representatives from both titalia
and crew log seek your services again both nations claim the
last strip of iraqian land between their countries few
iraqian castles remain in the area They are nothing more
than token resistance the most ferocious battles will occur
between Titania and Poulard Ironically this is how I would I
like I just kill everybody and then wait I brought overall
down a little bit sound guys the better now No matter which
side you fight for the other will perceive you as a traitor
It's always the winning side.
Your life depends upon it.
Alright.
Alright, do I want to do Goblin?
Okay.
Who was stronger?
Who had...
I don't know.
Oh my god, wait, what?
What do you mean two enemies?
In times of str... I don't remember which character had more
XP and stuff.
I don't even remember.
Your mercy and ways will earn you great rewards.
With Erythia collapsing under the weight of the...
It doesn't show me.
It just starts hero from borderlands or gold rush.
I'll be where some land grabbing has presented some in the
West.
Lands are ours for the taken.
Oh my god, guys, I think it's time.
I think...
I'm gonna do one more.
One more round.
And you know what that means.
you know what that i think it's time it's time for old
time's sake for for old time's sake it doesn't matter who i
play the time has come i am pleased that you have chosen the
side with us you have chosen how these stupid barbarians
fight with you will give you an advantage though it's very
likely that duke has put a price on your head for being a
traitor this will be a fight to the finish we wish to extend
our borders into the crew log hills and wish to stop us a
token of token european force will likely get caught in the
middle but there is simply nothing we can or wish to do
about it do well and you shall be idolized by all of
tatatria bell well we don't need to discuss that just yet
the letter is simply stamped with a scaly insignia of house
chalask don't worry i'll never fail
for old times sake guys let's make it real nostalgic
let's see you time to use the ancient text
what where's my oh wait I messed it up I messed it up so
what I would do I would do this and then I would do wait
that's not even my main guy where the fuck is my main bro oh
there he is I do that and then I do that and then I just do
this And then I would do this again and I would For old
times sake Cheater I told you I'll never lose Let's go
Yay Glorious victory!
Oh my god, how does she do it?
That was little Doki.
That was her.
I can't believe how good Doki is at this game.
Just for old times sake.
Just like how I remembered it, guys.
Just like how I remembered it.
Just like the good old days.
Okay, let's split all these guys.
Yeah, fuck it.
I'm too lazy to split it.
Just give it.
I'm too lazy to split all of this.
Too much splitting.
Just like the good old days.
Wasn't there more?
Oh, yeah, this one.
What is this?
You know what?
Let's just...
go all the way.
Let's just go all the way.
Since we're here.
One last round.
Use them all.
What's this?
Oh, yes.
Use them all.
What is this?
There's some that I've never even seen before.
The only sacred text I got was money and map and angels
let's see it oh here it is unlimited wait there's unlimited
fuck it we ball
oh you want to fight me let's go Oh my god, I didn't even
know there was, I didn't even know there's unlimited
movement.
My dad never gave me the sacred text.
Get out of here.
Don't leave.
That's right.
Leave.
It's always my turn.
I'll never stop being my...
turn that's the right it'll always be my turn you're gonna
jump out what you gonna do now it's my turn forever and ever
and ever oh my god Oh, you're scared.
You're so scared by the power of God.
It's my house now too.
Oh, yes.
Someone stop her.
You can't stop this.
I literally have God on my side.
I...
Oh, my God.
How dare you?
She's hitting me.
That's right, I'm coming for you.
I know there's another down here.
Oh, yoink, my house now.
Oh, where are you?
I know your ears somewhere.
Where are you?
Oh, where did you go?
I'm gonna find you.
Oh, yoink, my house now too.
Oh, no.
But the power the chief's given to me, I win.
Man, now they're all homeless.
That's right.
They're all homeless now.
It's my...
Oh, hey, yoink, my house.
There's still one more town somewhere.
find you.
Oh, I'm gonna find you.
I like how I fucked up that one move, and then even the game
was like, do you want another move?
And I was like, sure.
Sure, give me another move.
Sure.
I deserve it.
I definitely deserve another move.
Oh, look at that little guy guarding your house.
Look at him.
Oh, that's so cute.
He thought he could save his town.
Just like old times.
Did I took over everything?
Is it all mine now?
Did I win?
Has Tokey killed everyone yet?
Unlimited power.
Do you have all buildings.
Technically, I should have all of them.
Unlimited of power.
Oh my god.
I don't even need any of these.
What even is my wind condition?
I don't even know.
I don't even know what my wind condition is.
What even is it?
you must capture all towns regardless where are you hiding
where are you hiding there's still one more cheat i haven't
used you should reveal yourself soon oh yay
we did it it's hide and see Yay!
You can tell, see, I won.
There you go.
There, see?
This is, you're a rank cheater.
I did checkmate in one boop.
It was like Yu-Gi-Oh.
It was never the other person's turn.
Just like old times, chat.
Just like old times.
That was fun.
It was really fun.
Yeah, I wonder what that means.
I wonder what that...
Okay, so that was fun.
It was fun going back to some nostalgia games, some of the
games I grew up with.
I had a great time showing you guys Heroes of Might and
Magic.
uh eddie guerrero would be proud of you back there thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you i win so win i had
some things never change but i had a great time showing you
guys this game i've been wanting to play it for a while so
i'm glad i was able to show it to you guys and play it here
uh but we guys enjoyed watching uh maybe next time i'll
check out the new the fan mod i always know there was a fan
mob of new towns and everything so that might be fun to
check out um hey guys i'm gonna call it here as always
everybody say hi oh wait wait oh i forgot the codes again
tomorrow tomorrow i'll remember the codes tomorrow okay
anyway as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get
up and move around and get that blood flowing and you sit
for me head to bed because you deserve don't worry tomorrow
for sure the codes tomorrow sorry i got too into uh
Congratulations.
Your score.
Oh my god, I'm gonna be in the Hall of Fame!
Dokeybird, not.
Dokeybird, sacred text.
Text win.
There you go.
Learn me.
Hey guys.
Terminator, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is the best.
way to end this trip down memory lane.
Goons will have to be lying.
They claim they didn't use cheats at least once.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, sleepy.
Thank you, thank you.
Game just peek as fuck.
I know I love this game.
Hey, guys.
I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
I'll see you guys next time.
Bye, guys.
Bye.